Like midnight express.
God Damn,
it's been so long.
It's a in through the nose,
out through the mouth and
it's a lot of belly breathing.
It's all about the diaphragm.
You got to go Hixon Gracie
second.
I can't
really do that.
His son would you like to
get a cron can do it too.
Yeah,
it's bad ass.
I saw a video of him do it online.
Does it just like his father.
It's pretty freaky.
Yeah,
it's pretty awesome.
I'd watch just anybody.
Meanwhile I've lacked the discipline
to get that far down the road and the
breathing probably on a yoga.
Yeah,
that's what it is or
Marillo talking about it.
It's deep shit man.
And um,
you know,
we had a,
my friend Aubrey was on the other
day and he was talking about shamonic
breathing,
which they do intense bursts
of in through the nose,
out through the mouth,
into the nose,
out the mouth.
And if you do it for like 10 15 minutes,
apparently you reached this like crazy,
lucid,
euphoric state.
Sorry.
Oxygenated your blood or whatever.
Very strange psychedelic
experience apparently.
Yeah,
that's right.
You dirty fucks.
This podcast is brought to you
by [inaudible] dot com go to o,
n n I t use a code name,
Rogan and save yourself 10%
off any and all supplements.
We just added a new item.
It's called a t plus.
It's a testosterone supplement.
Yeah,
there's a lot of fuckery in the
world of testosterone supplements.
So we looked into it for a long time to
try to find out is there an effective
blend of nutrients that can
increase your testosterone?
Because there's a lot of different things
that are out there on the market that
may or may not work.
And the only thing that we could find for
sure that worked is all the stuff that
we put into this t plus formula.
I'm,
one of them is magnesium disparic acid,
which has been shown in at least one study
to increase free testosterone by 42%.
Um,
there's the,
there's magnesium and the zinc Zma.
Yeah.
You know,
I read into that Zma and one of the
things that it seems to increase
testosterone,
it just being completely honest about it.
I,
and I,
I take the product,
um,
they say that the way can help you is
that it can give you deep sleep and if you
are lacking in zinc,
then it can make up for that.
And boost testosterone is in
people who are lacking in zinc.
But apparently zinc is
just like really essential.
So a that just shows me that,
um,
zinc is,
it's a very important aspect of
normal health to keep you functioning,
but it don't,
I don't know if it necessarily
raises your testosterone.
It's,
it seems to only raise it and
people who are lacking in sync.
Um,
uh,
I was saying you suna [inaudible] um,
elevates your natural,
I know I fucked that up.
Elevates your natural dopamine levels,
which is a key neurotransmitter
involved in hormone hormone synthesis.
And we got this stuff called Long Jack.
It's like Euro Como long if Phila and
helps your body enhanced the synthesis of
various androgens produced by the testes,
which is your sac,
Aka your nuts son.
Um,
so what we did is we just,
we formulated all of this shit that
we could put together that work in a
synergistic fashion to,
uh,
to help elevate your body's testosterone.
The good thing about this is that this
is not something that your body would
become dependent upon and also that it
doesn't impede your natural production of
testosterone.
One of the issues with,
um,
if you take a testosterone replacement,
like I take a testosterone
cream and I rub it on.
And when you do,
the problem with doing
that is if you do too much,
if you have too much of it,
like if you get crazy,
like there's an issue
with MMA fighters where,
um,
they're on testosterone
replacement therapy.
Okay.
And the,
the real issue is,
okay,
well why are they lacking in testosterone
or they're lacking testosterone cause
they did steroids and then they're nuts.
Shutdown because that's what happens
when you do steroids and not shut down.
Then you can go to the
doctor and the doctor says,
oh,
well you're low on testosterone
and you look at them and you go,
wait a minute,
what the fuck is going on here?
This guy's a gorilla and
he's low on testosterone.
What is happening here?
So there's that.
And then there's also people
that start to get older.
Like myself,
I'm 45 years old.
At a certain point in time,
your body is just not going to produce
the same level of hormones is before.
And there's two ways about it.
You know,
you can either add testosterone to your
system or do something like this stuff.
I have not started this,
but I'm going to start trying this.
Um,
this isn't Zma.
This is something completely different.
Well,
it does have some magnesium in it,
but it has magnesium aspartic acid,
which has been shown in
actual clinical studies.
It's the key ingredient and Zma.
But it's been shown in clinical studies
that it actually can this one particular
aspect of it.
So will this still do the frothy loads?
I believe your loads
will stay frothy long.
Jack also builds up frothy loads,
long jack or something that
people have been using.
It's a,
some of the root or some shit it's people
have been using for a long time to,
to boost testosterone.
So,
um,
we're the pee wee,
we Beta test this on people.
They've had great results and
we're super excited about it.
So we think that a,
there's something to it.
We think that this is a,
um,
uh,
a supplement that the most important
thing is that it doesn't fuck with your
body's natural ability
to produce testosterone,
which the shit that I'm on does,
my balls would shut down.
Basically.
I said done.
I don't know.
He's not really because I
don't take that much of it.
I take a gram,
it's like a what you would put on a
tube of toothpaste and I rub it on,
sort of know my shoulders,
shoulders,
and your upper chest,
excuse me,
a little bit of test.
Not too much,
but,
but a lot of guys like I don't
want to be like this guy.
I got my wife pregnant twice while on it,
but,
so that means my boss still work.
But I know a lot of dudes,
they're balls don't work anymore.
They're done.
You know,
and there's some shit
you can take like Hcg,
I believe.
Yeah.
You can build your level of juvenile.
But it takes time.
Well,
what this is,
yeah,
this,
this video which you're looking at
right now is ridiculous and was more
ridiculous until I stepped in
because at the end of the video,
there's,
and thank you to the rogue and board and
all my freaks in the rogue and board.
Uh,
and I forgot which
individual pointed it out.
I forgive me,
but it's actually in the current farm.
This was,
which is the current farmers,
my area fruit problem.
Yeah.
Well the video is like,
he's getting a stretch on and then he
lifts and then afterwards he was at the
bar with these chicks and they were
pointing about how cheesy it was.
And I was like,
oh my God.
No,
because I always shit on this Stephen
Dorff commercial where he's smoking
cigarettes,
by the way.
This is in black and white,
which again,
makes it extra douchey.
That does make it extra duty.
She,
oh,
go ahead and start your,
here's your,
here's your car,
your queer.
Um,
the,
uh,
the video at the end was him at the
bar with two chicks and the music's
horrible.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
stop.
It was way worse than
Stephen Dorff commercial.
And it was like,
I can't be involved in this.
We also had to remove the word swagger.
Someone also pointed out your,
yeah,
the word swagger was involved.
Exactly.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
you're selling whenever you're involved
in anything enhancing like anything,
a male enhancing,
you have to really try hard to
avoid the stigma of Douchey lists.
Cause it's so easy to catch,
so easy to catch.
It's like,
well,
it's like being in a daycare
and not getting sick.
You're in a situation where you know,
you gotta you gotta you gotta
be real careful on that.
Exactly.
Anyway,
plenty of shit to buy it on a.com.
It's essentially a performance enhancing
website and that's really what it is.
All legal stuff.
But it's all about Alpha brain,
which,
uh,
I take for every podcast.
I take four of these for every podcast.
I take four of them before every UFC.
I take four of them before comedy shows.
Um,
it's,
these are essential building blocks
for human neurotransmitters and it can
enhance the way your mind functions.
For me,
it's an essential,
you know,
I've heard people say,
oh,
I don't feel anything on,
I mean,
you might not,
I don't know how your body works.
Everybody's body's completely different.
People have different
responses to alcohol.
People have different responses
to foods and allergies.
And for me,
it's a must have.
Um,
I'm,
I'm a huge believer in nootropics.
I've been a fan of him long before
I ever got involved in Alpha brain.
I took a bill Romanowski stuff,
which is called neuro one.
And Bill Romanowski created it because
he was having real issues with massive
headaches and head problems after all
the concussions that he took playing
football.
So he got involved in,
uh,
nutrients,
um,
to,
uh,
to make his mind healthier.
And,
uh,
I took some of his stuff,
found out about no name,
remember no name from Alison,
known name,
Sarah known him in San Francisco.
And from there I really got interested
and started just experimenting with
various different combinations of them.
And this is the best one so far from me.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
use the code name Brogan,
save 10% and go fuck yourself.
Holla.
We're also a sponsored by Squarespace.
Now this is,
this is the newest sponsor that we've got.
And if you've never been
a square per space before,
Squarespace is a,
it's pretty interesting.
It's essentially a website where you,
if you go to squarespace.com
forward slash Joe,
um,
you can sign up and
you can check this out.
It's,
it allows you to make your own
websites without being like a red band,
like a computer genius.
I've actually thought about using coder
guys just because it seems the way to go
nowadays.
Yeah.
Like I don't feel like doing
all the old stuff anymore.
He nowadays like these
templates and like these like,
like build your own website.
Things are so good that it does the
purpose that it's almost a no brainer.
Yeah.
With someone who like
marginal intelligence,
like a normal brain.
You can,
you can go there and you can make a dope
website that works by the way on every
platform.
And it'll work on mobile
platforms as well.
It's really interesting shit.
squarespace.com forward slash Joe.
And if you use the Co,
the,
uh,
the Code Joe too,
you can get 10% off your first
purchase on a new accounts,
including monthly and annual plans.
So use the offer code Joe
and the number two Joe too.
I don't know why Joe too.
I guess cause there's a Joe
one and that makes me sad.
Oh,
you need a change.
You need to change it to something else.
We're going to do Joe,
not Joe too,
but I'm Joe too.
I know,
I know.
The second fucking me man.
The square base people are fucking me,
man.
The taco Joe the gave me,
I don't really care.
I'm an easy going guy.
A taco Joe Taco.
That's even harder.
Man was a Burrito.
Jodes fuck a Burrito,
Joe.
It's bullshit
that you fucking asshole.
Uh,
Squarespace.
Squarespace has an award
winning design team,
user experience experts.
Like if you look at the,
the layouts,
like each template has hundreds
of customer customization
options that you can
change the grid layout,
the colors,
there's 300 fonts.
I mean you can do some
bad ass shit and it's fun.
And the way it's made intuitive
and it's like it doesn't,
it doesn't work.
It doesn't stress you out.
It allows you to just be
creative and you know,
you could go and look online.
There's a lot of really cool websites
that have been made from it and you know,
you can get kind of ideas of
how you could do your own shit.
But it's cool because it's,
it allows the regular person person
who's not some genius coder character to
create something pretty bad
ass that represents you on a,
on the Internet.
So go and check it out.
If you go to squarespace.com/joe no
credit card needed to try it out.
No,
no,
no.
That's the [inaudible]
can offer code.
You're ruining the whole show.
Bryan,
squarespace.com Ford
Slash Joe Joe.
That's how you go there when
you want to use the offer code.
If you decide to purchase,
use the offer code Joe and the
number two together Joe too.
So no credit card is needed.
If you want to try it out,
you can just go there and say,
let me see what is this worth.
Giving them my money.
You can try it out and
start building a website.
Then if you decide to purchase it,
use the offer code show
too and you save 10% off.
It's pretty dope.
I mean really is the future.
We're,
we're in a a cool time when they've
figured out how to make it really easy for
like the person to put together like a
really bad ass professional website and
so we're real excited about this.
So go to Squarespace and go fuck yourself.
Hey.
Alright.
Oh higher primate higher slash primate.com
all the tee shirts and backend though
medium of the monkey astronauts
has already sold out.
That's,
that's how crazy wow shit
is flying off the shelves.
You've dirty fucks.
So go there size you already.
Medium side,
dirty fucks,
higher-primate.com.
Um,
eventually we're going to,
we're going to push this business over
to on it so they'll take a much better
care of it than I am on my own.
Cause I'm,
I'm,
I'm just,
I don't have the time.
That makes perfect sense.
It makes perfect sense.
I'm just not that good at fucking
keeping up on inventory an ideas guy.
Exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I've always said.
Jesus Christ,
man.
Why don't they listen to Sam Sheridan?
Um,
so higher-primate.com go there now and
that's the fucking end of the commercials
freaks.
Sam Sheridan is here.
He's got an awesome new book.
I am fucking pumped up.
I've been reading it.
It's dope as fuck.
Let's talk.
Awesome to be here.
I think about it.
I'm like,
you know what?
I can't wait to get
into the Rogan version.
The Rogan questions hit it.
[inaudible]
yes,
either.
I'll never do that.
Yeah,
you can't.
It's very important part of the critical,
we're back from a week vacation.
Sorry for everybody that got the Jones.
I appreciate it.
I appreciate all the tweets and
the messages and everything we had,
but we had to take some time off.
Shit was getting,
getting a little stale,
get a little crazy,
fresh it up.
During my time off,
I was reading the disaster diaries.
It was um,
it's really speaks to like
how I view the world and uh,
excellent.
Very,
I mean it was like you were like inside
my head with so many different aspects
of the idea of,
of disasters,
the idea of taking care
of your kids and that,
that extra feeling of vulnerability that
you have now being a father as opposed
to the way you were when
you were a young man.
Just you're a whatever.
Fuck yeah,
I'll be all right.
Um,
the book's called the disaster diaries,
how I learned to stop worrying
and love the apocalypse and uh,
it's really fucking interesting stuff man.
And you went,
you went really deep with this.
You covered so many aspects of the whole
idea of survival and the whole idea of
like really chaos situations
and controlling your
adrenaline and relaxing and
how most people really have no idea
that like when the shit hits the fan,
most people are just literally
going to like shut off,
they're going to shit
their pants and shut off.
And that is a much more
common reaction than not.
Totally.
Yeah.
So interesting to see that.
Like,
you know,
a lot of people know what they don't know.
You know what I mean?
And that's,
that was kind of,
so one of the major,
you know,
sort of things I took from
this book was what stress does,
you know,
you and I,
you've been in the fight game for a
long time and I'd written about the
fighter's mind and stuff
and I was shocked at how,
you know,
the Cooper's color code wasn't
talked about in the fight game.
You know what I mean?
Which,
you know,
it's a shooting thing.
Explain to Cooper.
So,
so it's in the book,
the Cooper's color code,
which anybody who does any shooting,
we'll know about it.
But,
but it's basically,
Jeff Cooper was a very well known farms
instructor in the 60s and he came up
with this color code about your sort
of alertness level and you know,
white,
you're at home kind of off or listening
to music or watching TV and then yellow,
you're on the street and not orange.
You're,
you know,
you sort of seeing maybe possible
danger and then read you're fighting.
And that was how he sort of quantified it.
And then the Marine Corps
later come up with black,
which was the catastrophic
failure of your mind,
basically like the total breakdown.
And it was just so interesting.
They sort of,
you know,
I've been sort of hearing about this
anecdotally and I'd seen it with fighters.
Um,
you know,
guys freezing or just doing
dumb shit over and over again.
You know,
it's not working,
but they can't stop and they're
getting punched in the face.
So that's definitely
not helping them there.
But you know,
the fact that,
I mean,
I'm sure some of these
trainers knew about it,
but nobody had mentioned,
you know,
there's this huge raft of data
and research that's been done on,
on,
on stress and what it
does to your body and,
and,
uh,
it wasn't,
you know,
really being utilized in the fight game.
I think the psychological aspect of
finding is one of the most overlooked
aspects and it's also one
of the most important.
It's um,
you wrote about it in the fighter's mind
and there's two great books for folks,
by the way,
if you're a MMA fans,
the fighters hard and the fighter's mind,
uh,
both of them are written by our
friend Sam and a you actually,
so people know you actually fuck yourself.
And I watched that.
Um,
it just flipping through the channels
one day I watched that video of you and
the Thai camp,
really a amazing video.
It was really cool.
It's followed you long
before you were an author,
right?
Yeah.
That was a long time ago.
Yeah,
it was just a kid.
But yeah,
it was cool.
You lived in a Thai camp
for like five months and uh,
had,
uh,
how many fights did you have fought?
One time.
And that one dude that you fought was
like this fucking karate champion.
He was obviously bad ass,
but you out conditioned him.
Yeah.
He wasn't a,
he wasn't a,
it wasn't shameful.
The coat.
Yeah,
the pace and all that.
He was really good though.
Well he knocked me.
He was good.
Yeah,
he was better then I was sharp.
Like I remember his technique,
my defense,
that was my first flight of any kind.
Right.
You know what I mean?
So like it wasn't like I had
any amateur fights and you know,
I had friends who fought and
they couldn't even a punch.
They were so nervous
or they couldn't kick,
they could only punch.
They were like robots.
You know what they got.
And so,
you know,
yeah,
I felt like shit.
But you know my mind at all.
You fuck great man.
I did all right.
But I'll listen.
I chased them around with my hands
down and then I went out like a,
like a plank.
He caught you and you watch the way
he caught you.
That was a season fighter.
Yeah,
he did.
He definitely,
he had a lot of experience.
It's funny,
you know Duke Roufus just
tweeted me and he was like,
you know,
I really like that.
And it's like I got a little light.
Well it's a great,
Duke is a huge [inaudible] fan and it's
a great video because it focuses on you.
This guy who wants this real true Moitai
immersion experience and that's one of
the things that I find unique about you.
One of the things I really always
love to talk to you about it,
it's like you're one of the rare
people that I know that just you,
we'll just fucking go and do something
and you immerse yourself in these worlds
that are like really precarious
and fucking dangerous and you're,
you're really into doing that.
You're really into taking these chances
and getting the full experience.
So that's what you did in this,
this Thai camp.
You lived there for five months,
was that one?
Yeah,
that's six months,
five,
six months,
something in that.
And I fought at the end and then a,
and then I bailed.
But yeah,
I mean I think I do,
I do love to immerse myself and you know,
I sort of kind of do like
almost social anthropology.
You know,
I'd go get into these other subcultures.
But one of the things I don't do is like,
I don't really have adventures
cause I feel like adventures is,
you know,
it's when you run out of the list,
it's when you run out
of gas in the desert,
you know what I mean?
It's like you fucked up,
you fucked up and now you
have an adventure now,
now you're in trouble.
Whereas if you plan and you,
and you got your eyes and you know,
you cover your basis,
you don't really have adventures,
you do cool shit,
but it's not dangerous and you're not,
you know,
I think that's a semantics thing
because I call those adventures.
Yeah,
know.
Sure.
It's,
it is.
But I think there's a,
there's an important like kind
of context and there's a lot of,
you know,
of course I think about having
Tanner and I also think about,
you know guys who,
who,
you know have too much faith in
their strength into the wild,
into the wild McCandless
in that whole scene.
Yeah.
You got to that into the wild.
Drove me crazy because I'm,
this kid was supposed to be smart.
Well if you're supposed to be smart,
how the fuck do you
not prepare for Alaska?
Like you're,
this is quilting
here.
You know,
the thing is he was,
listen,
I read the book and I've
thought a lot about it and I,
and I,
you know,
I've talked to guys about it and cause,
cause I was doing all the
survival stuff for disaster diary.
So is that what this guy in Kansas who
does survival school training for the
Sayre instructors.
So the guys who teach survive,
evade,
resist,
escape school to the seals and stuff.
He takes three of those guys.
There are instructors and
teachers in these skills.
He's like,
fire,
making Flint knapping making
little trap stuff like that.
Um,
and we know we talked
about McCandless and,
and,
and that guy in into the wild.
And um,
I think what motivated
sort of the story was yeah,
he was foolish,
but also he made a mistake
that locals make that,
so he ate something that
that makes you sick.
It looks like something you can eat.
I don't think that's true.
It wasn't the reality
that he starved to death.
Yeah,
no he did.
But this,
this is what happened.
So he got sick,
but he was too close to the edge,
so he was so he was,
so he then he starved to death because
he was so weakened at that point.
So he w he didn't have the supplies and
this is what Krakauer writes about and
this is what,
so he couldn't,
he didn't have the energy
to go get food basically.
Yeah.
Once you get,
like if you're on the edge of survival
and you're at the caloric kind of,
you know,
right at the cutoff of make,
of eating enough and you're,
you're in a,
you're dying all the time
and then you get sick,
you're fucked.
You know what I mean?
You're in the wild and you
have no one to help you.
So he made a mistake that
should have given them diarrhea,
but because he was so weak,
he killed them.
Oh Wow.
And he starved to death because in
the movie they made it out that it was
something poisonous that killed him.
It was,
yeah,
no it was,
but it just makes you say,
it gives you like a little
intestinal diarrhea or whatever.
Change that in the movie.
Why,
why don't they do shit like that?
Sean Penn,
right.
I don't know,
mother Fucker,
Sean.
Um,
but the,
in the,
somebody,
somebody told me that in the real
life he had actually starved to death,
but I didn't know that part.
I never read the book again.
I could be wrong and this is my or
sort of recollection of the incident.
Um,
but,
and,
and how it went down.
And I talked to this guy,
um,
uh,
John Macpherson who does these survival
stuff in Kansas and there's a lot of
plants that are poisonous that
looked like edible cause that's,
yeah,
that's kind of the
nature of edible plants.
And sometimes they,
you know,
the other plants disguise themselves,
whatever.
You know what I mean?
There's this,
so you can make that
mistake pretty easily,
I guess.
Yeah.
There's a group of old people that live
in an old folks home and one of the
ladies went out and pick mushrooms
and this bitch can't see anymore.
So she got all these poisoned mushrooms,
cooked them up for
everybody and they all died.
Wow.
Punch of in China,
I think it was American man.
I don't think it was a
Florida or some shit.
Yeah,
no.
And what his point was is like,
you know,
if he's trying to survive,
you're trapping animals and
eating the whole animal.
Yeah.
Which was kind of interesting.
Getting your nutrients from like
eating the brain and eating right,
eating,
you know,
all the work.
He didn't know how to prepare the food.
And he didn't also know.
He didn't know how to keep it.
Like he fucked up the Mousse.
That's what I asked him about.
Actually it's in the book
I asked Macpherson about,
you know,
what you do with,
cause he in,
in into the wild,
he kills a moose and he doesn't
know what to do with it.
He tries to dry it but flies.
But if you cut it just thin enough,
so all it is is you cut strips of in,
you need a sharp knife,
you cut strips.
As long as it's under a
half inch or a quarter inch,
it's in the book,
but it's like a thick,
so it's thin sheets and you're hanging
out to dry and you get some sun.
The flies won't lay eggs in it
and it turns into Jerky Dude.
Yeah,
they do that in Mexico.
Yeah.
Buffalo.
They take these strips.
It's this weird technique
that I saw on Steve Rinella.
Shell [inaudible] he takes these,
they take these strips of meat and they
hang them over a line in the hot sun.
Right.
Then they take them and
they smashed them up.
Right.
And then they re they put water in it
and they cook it and it's called the
Chaka.
Right.
Well this is just the
preserve to make jerky.
All you do is dry it and
it's really not very edible,
but it's me.
It'll keep you alive.
And it's,
yeah,
it's uh,
it's,
I didn't know Turkey was that simple.
Like,
you know,
you sort of think there's
something complicated and
they put a lot of spices and
you buy it.
But um,
yeah,
you just dry it.
And uh,
it's interesting that it's
cooked meat is more dangerous.
Raw meats not that
dangerous for some reason.
You know,
he gets cooked meat,
like the Salmonella gets in it and
you die from that shit or whatever.
But Raleigh,
yeah.
This,
these guys would go out and they would
have a big hunk of raw meat and they
would hang it under a tree with a wet
towel wrapped around it and leave it for
the week.
And that was their fridge.
And they would just carve off pieces.
They cooked the pieces,
you know,
so once you,
once you heat it up,
but it wouldn't,
how rotten was it?
I don't think it was that bad.
And where was this?
What part of they weren't Kansas.
Jesus Christ.
Fucking crazy.
I know.
It's weird shit.
But you know,
it's like,
it keeps it a little cool.
And then I,
I didn't do that.
But that's what he,
that's what I saw them week in Kansas.
And what is the
temperature is in November.
He knows summertime,
summertime.
So they were hunting out of
season these mother fuckers,
is that what they're doing?
He might've been,
or the mother had like,
you know,
they might've had this
roadkill or something.
It might not have been somewhere.
It might've been fall.
I don't know.
It was something he had done with
some guys then they live primitive.
So they didn't have any,
uh,
steel tool.
I would imagine you could do that.
I mean,
when I went to your hunting,
we hung the deer's outside
for like a couple of days,
but it was only 12 degrees outside.
Right.
It's like you didn't
have to worry about it,
but the,
the idea of like a Kansas summer.
Yeah.
Fucking deer leg with a
towel wrapped around it.
It's like the jungle
that can be good for you.
Right.
They see that I'm the most
important things to cook or
things that eat meat like
bears and pigs like bear.
The kidney can kill you
apparently like the kid.
He's like soup.
I think so.
Really?
There's something in a bear.
You,
you cannot eat.
It's poison.
Hmm.
It'll actually kill you dead.
Ooh.
And it's edible and like herbivores.
Well yeah,
you can eat kidneys and other things and
you should eat them in other things and
a or live or maybe it's liver.
I Dunno.
There's something that
a bear you can't eat.
Hunger would make sense.
Yeah.
It's the liver.
Well,
if they,
I'm livers like bears
like some bears there,
they eat a lot of garbage too.
Like you gotta be real careful.
Apparently in New Jersey they just started
allowing people to hunt black bears
because they have so many black bears
that are like rating garbages and getting
in the streets and stuff like that.
But the issue is if you get a
bear that's been eating garbage,
it's going to taste like shit.
Yeah.
So you're shooting this thing and it's,
you know,
you're not even going to eat it.
You know what,
I'm going to enjoy it.
Well,
like the deer in Kansas there,
they're basically grain fed cattle
because they're eating the grains and the
cattle are eating and stuff.
So they have all the cattle
issues and it's not like,
oh,
that's true.
Yeah,
and big and fat.
But they're,
you know,
it's not like great deer meat.
Oh,
that's right.
I didn't even think of that.
Apparently a Alfalfa,
it's like one of the
best foods for the year.
And then eat Alfalfa though,
like super healthy.
It's like people will grow a whole field
of Alfalfa because just to make sure
the deer come in Alfalfa,
like there's these gray areas,
these places called high fence operations.
They set it up.
So they kind of like,
Ted Nugent has one,
only trap all these
deer and like whatever.
He's gotten,
Michigan,
he's got one in Michigan and one Texas.
She's got like in Texas,
I know he has 300 acres.
I don't know what he has.
It's like shooting fish
in a barrel kind of.
Yeah.
But you know you have like a certain
amount of space and they're in there.
Yeah.
You know,
and they're eating Alfalfa.
So it's like on one hand it's a smart
move here on a prime for the apocalypse.
Yeah.
I mean if you have a setup like that
and you're planning for the apocalypse,
that's pretty dope.
Cause apparently mean,
think about a deer.
You could eat a deer for a long ass time.
You shoot one day or you're
good for like a month,
right of every day.
So if you have like a whole
property filled with them,
that would be good.
No,
I mean there's a lot of like ideal
situations and that was kind of the,
one of the scary things about this
book was like not having the bunker.
Right.
And and or do I build a bunker or where
do I build the bunker but do it in
Montana.
Wait all the minute man,
sites from Montana.
And I think what I got into
really was that Black Swan issue,
which is you just don't know
what the disaster is going to be.
You don't know if it's going to be x,
y,
or Z.
And until you do the
bunker could be a danger.
It can be a crutch because
you depend on the bunker.
It's like you're mentally hooked to this
bunker because you put so much time and
money into it.
You're not ready to
leave when it's time to
go.
I think one of the most important things
that you emphasize in this book is just
preparing your physical body and
not just by getting in shape,
but by understanding stress and by putting
yourself in stressful situations and
making yourself sort of recover and,
and,
and handle that.
The inoculation to stress idea.
That was a really interesting
point that you brought up.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's what,
you know,
again,
the military,
you know,
and even sports psychology is about,
sports psychology.
It's just much lower levels of stress
cause you're not scared you're going to
die.
Um,
but in an MMA fight,
fighting Anderson Silva,
you might read it as though you're still,
you know,
I have some of this condition black,
if you're in Rio and
you're fighting habits,
right?
The black right,
they have that.
They have that chance.
I don't know what they're saying,
but apparently saying you're going to
die calling for blood and they're all
yelling out,
you're going to die in Portuguese.
It's like,
Ooh,
Ooh.
They do all fucking these 18,000 of them,
the screen.
And then you're looking across the
octagon and Anderson Silva's there.
You might think you're going,
I might have her passion black reaction.
Yeah.
And we went into that a little bit,
but explaining to people that condition
black is when your heart rate and
everything gets to a point where you're,
your adrenaline is too high
and you can't think rationally.
So your,
your Amygdala,
which recognizes a these things
subconsciously or consciously.
But you see a threat and your body of
course does fight or flight right and boom
fills your,
you know,
your body with adrenaline and
other chemicals and you're,
you know,
everything changed.
Everything changes.
So your,
your,
your eyeball actually changes shape and
your fine motor skills really sell for
because you know,
your muscles will fill
up and you can have,
you know,
trouble tying things.
There was a,
you know,
Navy Seals,
they were at the end of
a really rugged course.
They were trying to um,
uh,
they had to handcuff these,
you know,
what the plastic zip ties these,
these,
these other trainees and the
guys who had pre threaded,
it had no problem.
The who hadn't spent minutes trying to,
cause even though they're navy
seals and they're bad ass,
like they,
it was just there were so
filled with adrenaline.
It made it so hard for
them to even get that,
the thread,
that little,
well,
the proper,
you know,
also gross movements when
you tax out those muscles.
Yes.
It very hard to operate everything.
More skill.
Totally.
And then your,
your cognitive ability
gets sit down and you know,
I always think of what
Brian's story about.
He got mugged and he dialed a
four one one right over and over.
Yeah,
because I was trying to
call nine one one you know,
it's so like shaky that couldn't,
like my fingers wouldn't work.
I'm sitting there
staring at my phone like,
why is this not chick?
Why is it,
what am I doing right?
It's actually really common,
which is the paramedics.
They'll say that if it's a loved one
that's a hurt and you're losing your mind.
A lot of people will die cap to get the
neighbor to call nine one one because
they can't actually operate the phone.
So you think,
oh,
I'll be all right.
You know?
But truth is like people get so fucked up,
they can't operate phone,
they can't dial nine one which
is you think would be impossible,
but it does happen.
We are weird animal in
the fact that we're,
we're conscious.
Yeah.
So you're kind of aware of all these
things that are happening and you're not
just operating on instinct.
Like basically every other animal on this
whole planet is just operating purely
on instincts.
We are aware of scenarios that have
taken place before and the possible
repercussions for those scenarios or
those all roll around in our mind,
a sea of possibilities and
then it can shut you down.
And then the whole not having
experience with stress,
we're not,
and that's what animals
diffuses,
you know that.
So the two ways you can do it,
our training,
which is like military,
you repeated a million times or sports,
you'd do it a million times.
So even when you're
stressed out of your mind,
you still can do it.
Yeah.
Where are your,
your movement is a natural move
on instead of the contract,
securely ingrained and
you've very efficient,
you know,
nurse,
some nap tickly or whatever
and all that stuff.
Or you can,
you know,
have experience and that's the
inoculation against stress,
which if you've been
through similar things,
you know,
this isn't going to kill you.
You know,
I always think about how important
it is for fighters and fatigue.
Uh,
when they get so exhausted and you,
you know,
the lactic acid is filling
their body and you know this,
cause you,
you roll and you and
you fight and all that,
but it's like you feel like you're gonna
die.
Yeah.
You really looking for a way out.
And if you,
as long as you know your,
if you've been through it a few times,
you know,
hey,
I'm not going to die.
That feeling that I want to die does
not mean that I am going to die.
And so I can keep going and rest.
That's why wrestlers are so good
at them and may because they,
they're,
they're mentally so
ready for that fatigue.
And that's all wrestling really is,
you know,
is,
is managing that fatigue
and managing that push.
So,
um,
and then also the exhaustion
that they get from dehydration,
that fatigue is the mental
toughness comes from that.
Do you know about this thing where
they're going to remove wrestling for the
weapon?
Is that the nuttiest fucking,
yeah,
it seems like it's all real political.
And just,
you know,
feel a fucked up.
But it's also like the,
I dunno,
sees a mess by the way.
I mean,
oh yeah.
Well because you know racist,
they were like,
there's like a real neo Nazi background.
The Olympic,
the Olympic Games.
Really?
Yeah.
If you look at who ran it,
that's,
so you don't have that,
that famous picture in
the 60s of those guys.
The black power salute.
You know they're wearing gloves.
Yes.
Cause they didn't want their skin to
touch the hand of once they metaled of the
guy who was handing out the medals
because he was an affirmed neo Nazi.
Wow.
So he told them to put gloves he wore,
they wore gloves because they
didn't want to touch his skin.
That's why they're wearing gloves.
Yeah.
The guys in the sixth,
it's like one of them was Austrian
and if I forget the exact thing,
but it was like one of them,
the forties and then his
successor in the 60s were like,
had these real like Neo
Nazi sympathies is shit.
So the Olympics has like some shading,
this dirty business.
It's up there.
I'm,
I'm real vague about this,
but wasn't there like
almost everything else,
but wasn't there a thing about a couple
of years ago where there was a big
scandal briberies and a
bunch of things in the IOC?
I'm sure there was some sort of scandal.
Know what I mean?
It's all,
it's,
it's a pretty,
it always ends up ruining the city,
costing them kajillion dollars and who
knows where the money goes to developing
and
it bothers me also that the
athletes don't get money.
That just seems crazy.
The idea of that,
not giving them some sort
of a financial prize.
W where's all that money going?
It's what they're getting an opportunity.
They are your number one
thing that you're selling.
Number one,
you're saying thing you're selling
is the performance of the athletes.
That's number one and you're making
billions and they don't get any.
That's fucking crazy.
I don't care what you call it,
amateur,
but it's amateur.
It's amateur.
That sounds like slavery.
It sounds like an onsite,
I feel the same way about the NCAA and
football [inaudible] they're making so
much money and the athletes are getting
compensated college athletes crazy.
I mean this is crazy,
but it's like that doesn't,
you know,
the idea is that it's
up through and around.
Yeah,
it's a proving ground and it launches
them into the net and the ideal also,
I think I get a little bit more
with the Ncaa because they should be
concentrating on their education and
this is a side aspect of it and that
education is building towards,
but I think that the idea that the
school just profits completely off of it.
It goes to maybe the money
should go to programs,
maybe all the profits that should go
to the athletes and instead go to pro.
I mean imagine how rich those schools
would be and their ability to go after
school dungeons and dragons,
baroque music programs and
kind of make it to pick it.
Right?
They should get to pick which,
helping their community out.
Think about the amount
of money that the NCAA,
you know,
creates and think about how much
benefit that could be for any community.
If they took like a sizeable chunk,
like 50% like what are the,
what are like hockey players just
bargain for 50% and so it was,
they had more somewhere else.
The NBA,
all the,
you know,
the unions.
Imagine if the NCAA football guys got
50% like people don't realize how much
money is in college sports.
I didn't realize it until Joey Lane.
Shocking.
Like the Penn state thing.
This sex scandal made no sense to me.
I was like,
how did this not get outed?
That's crazy.
Who would,
and then I found out how much money you
can state makes every year from their
football program and
from getting donations.
It's in the billions.
Yeah.
What the alumni,
the spa.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's insane.
And when you get that high,
you're going to get people that are doing
whatever they can to keep that thing.
That way,
if that,
if that amount of money,
half of it like was just like,
okay,
these guys,
essentially they're professionals.
But instead of giving them the money,
we're going to give it to
the community thought yeah,
that'd be me.
And it would grow.
Keep those fat cons from getting fatter.
Those motherfuckers,
but rich pitches out there just stealing
from these young urban kids with good
legs.
That's right.
Handsome kids fuckers.
They're given him a shot.
I mean I,
I get that,
but somebody,
I don't know.
Yeah.
I still feel like,
you know the injury
rate and all that stuff,
you know.
Oh that's true too.
What was that one young guy who was
like a real promising football player.
Just blue.
It's just at any moment man.
And then one with the hand of God
can come and just no more for you.
The circles your whole life
actually the hand a probability,
right?
Yeah.
Cause it's such a dangerous
occupationally running into people,
full black running super
athletes at each other,
like a gladiator moving.
Right.
It's like,
it's also what you're paying for is
that sort of what people want to see.
And,
um,
this,
one of the other things about your book,
about the Color Code that freaked me out
was the stories of cops with their gun
on safety with their tendons
exploded in their fingers,
shot dead because they're
gun was on safety and they
kept squeezing the trigger,
but nothing was happening.
Video of a,
of a cop who is just
saying drop the weapon,
drop the weapon.
And he's what they call a
stuck on the behavioral loop.
So that's condition black.
So when you get so stressed
out that your heart rate is,
you know,
very,
very high,
175 beats per minute or whatever it is,
it's,
you have what they called dissociation.
So you start having perceptual
issues like time moves slowly.
You don't hear things,
you don't see things.
A tunnel vision,
like the gun,
all you can see is the barrel of the gun,
right or whatever.
And you get behavioral looping.
Like people do the same
thing over and over again.
So like,
you know,
they're stuck in the,
in the nightclub and they're
trying to open the door.
Right.
Door is locked,
but they stayed there for 10
minutes because that's it.
That's their only thing.
Or the cops are pulling their,
you know,
pull and trying to find,
work their weapon.
Or is there's a video of this cop yelling,
drop the weapon,
and then the guys reloading,
oh and drop the weapon.
And then he shoots the cop and
he couldn't get out of that loop.
And again,
what's interesting about it
is it makes sense if you're,
if we're cavemen,
like if there's a wolf,
you know,
chewing on my arm and I'm losing my mind,
I'm like,
just keep hitting them
with a rock like this.
You've got to just keep doing that.
Like that's,
that's your survival.
That's,
that's it.
That's my best plant,
you know?
Right.
But in the modern world where you
have a need for critical thinking,
you know,
you need like,
even this guy's in the,
in the nightclub fire
and in Brazil recently,
uh,
some of those guys were,
were Facebook and me
and talking about what,
what worked and what didn't
work and how they got out.
And you know,
the guys and a lot of them didn't,
you know,
it was,
there wasn't a way out,
but hundreds of people,
right?
Yeah.
And it's terrible.
But you know,
I'm not like an next,
I didn't really study it in depth,
but again,
the critical thinking.
So finding ways out,
finding,
you know,
thinking,
being able to step back and go,
oh,
there's another exit in the kitchen.
There's always an exit in the kitchen,
you know,
and,
and uh,
and get getting to it is,
is the trick.
And you know,
when you're in condition black,
you can't get there.
You know,
you can't,
that's the whole problem is like,
you can't think of it.
You know,
you can't see yourself clearly enough.
And this is the thing that,
you know,
that people do call it combat breathing,
where they take,
you know,
four deep breaths on a four count,
which is great if you can think to do it,
you know what I mean?
But again,
the problem is you don't know you're
in condition black when you're in
conditioned black,
right.
And it's this,
it's Nick's up on you
in the inevitability of our demise is in
the back of our head and when all of a
sudden you're confronted by it,
like gets here.
Yeah.
It becomes exponentially more stressful
than it is for an animal because even
though an animal instinctively knows
it's got to get the fuck away from you,
I don't think they can really calculating,
quantify all the possibilities.
And when we do,
it's like it's paralysis by analysis.
It's the adrenaline
dump and the heart rate.
What does the heart rate when
you're in condition black?
It depends.
You know,
it's,
it's very,
it's all specific to the person,
but you know,
175 so it's like one whole sprinting.
Yeah.
And it's not from exercise at all.
So it's just from adrenaline.
There's actually a,
which makes it really hard to breathe.
There's this thing called the V,
so Vega vagal response,
and you know,
the Vegas is a nerve,
but the way it was put to me,
which I thought was great was it's a,
it's a,
it's in the book,
Dude.
I,
it's like,
it's myelinated nerve
colonnade and response.
So it's a polyvagal theory illegal
basically like this a Reptilian reptilian
part of your brain.
Right?
You know,
we all know that and there's
two kinds of Vegas that,
that operate possibly and,
and uh,
one is Reptilian,
one has mammalians rights,
but if the reptilian one gets into it,
that can slow you down and make you
freeze and the Mammalian one wants you to
run,
run.
Right?
So it's like stepping on the gas pedal
and the brake at the same time as hard as
you can.
And that's what condition black is.
You think about doing that in your car,
getting your car and just jumping on the
gas and the brake as hard as you can.
That happens that people panic
in automobile accidents as well.
Yeah.
People think they're hitting the
brake and the hitting the gas,
I've hit the brake by
accident when you're hitting,
you know what I mean?
Like,
Oh shit.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
They were right next door.
I really fucking close the,
the,
the modern life we live is so soft.
It's so easy,
the ability to go to Jack in the box and
feed your fat face while you're still
in your,
which
you,
you know,
you didn't build that car,
you didn't design it.
And how it works.
Easy job at an easy place where you're
not stressing at all during the day.
You're just doing whatever
the fuck you gotta do,
Sell Insurance,
whatever it is.
I mean,
whatever normal stress you have
from sending in a normal office,
but your body literally is never taxed.
If you're the average person
that doesn't exercise,
you've reached a level of the human
animal has reached a level that doesn't
exist in nature
and animal that can't survive on its own,
attached symbiotically
cultural since two hour two.
Well you can't make it.
Even a dog can fucking go
out there and kill rat a rat.
You know,
what are you going to do?
Yeah,
well most of them.
And I think the,
what I realized because I did that,
so I was getting ready for the end
of the world in various scenarios.
And I did work outs and uh,
you know,
I,
did a bunch of different stuff.
But one of the important
things about fitness is,
is it keeps your mind ready for the
disaster you can handle and adrenaline
better if you're in good shape.
You know,
and if you've gotten your sleep,
you know,
it,
a lot of those breakdowns happen
when people are sleep deprived.
So,
you know,
you read about people that have had
panic attacks and a lot of it comes after
they have insomnia for a long time,
you know,
sleep,
not getting your sleep is huge.
All that shit.
Yeah.
What a strange animal.
You know,
the fact that we need
to shut off every night.
Well they were kind of,
most of them do.
Right.
But what a weird property of our existence
that we have to shut off the world is
so stressful.
You have to spend a third of it
not paying attention and that,
and we don't even exactly
know why you need to do it.
I mean we're,
we're so confused on what exactly is
going on during rem sleep and we know you
the aspects,
we know hormones Murray.
And the real issue is the psychedelic
drugs that your brain releases while
you're sleeping.
That's when things get really
fucked up and you're like,
what is going on when you're dreaming?
And what happens to people who don't
get the dream ended up having psychotic
breakdown?
They get crazy.
Yeah.
When they've done studies where they've
kept people awake for days at a time,
like people literally lose their shifts.
They kind of breakdown.
Yeah.
That'd become psychos.
48 hours,
72 matches being tired like
your mind just delusion.
Yeah.
Fuck out.
It just doesn't function right.
It's very,
very odd.
Yeah.
It's interesting cause a lot of this
stuff like they are doing a lot more
science of fear now,
right.
So they're like,
they're putting electrode caps on people
and chucking them out of airplanes and
sort of so they can really
sort of see what's happening.
So there's some interesting new books,
like extreme fear.
Jeff Wise's book is pretty cool.
Like it's about what,
even a jumping out of an airplane.
It's sort of a controlled situation.
Like yeah,
you're shitting your pants,
cause your pair of shooting,
but you're not fighting Anderson Silva.
You're not,
you know,
you're not in a car accident and it's not,
it's not like the building's on fire.
It's your,
what I love about what I was
like about MMA and stuff does he,
you get to train for it and
you know,
nobody's going to hit you behind
the head with a two by four.
You know what I mean?
It's like you get ready.
Yeah.
And we're,
I always worried about myself was like,
what if I'm not ready?
Yeah.
And I'm just driving home and the
shit hits the fan and I'm like,
uh,
you know,
how long would it take me to adjust
my reality to this new reality?
Yeah.
Being prepared is such a relief.
It's a relief thing too.
It relieves stress.
Yeah,
well that's where I want it to go.
You know what I realized was like,
I don't want to be paranoid and be a
doomsday prepper because I think sometimes
that then ends up being
a counter productive.
Like you,
you know the anxiety is
making you less relaxed.
Right?
You're more worried,
you're more fearful of your neighbors
and you're more convinced of like,
I got to shoot everybody.
Know what I mean?
People.
Yeah.
That way they're going to,
they're ready to go.
You know,
they got their guns and
they were ready to go.
There's a lot of those folks,
they're just ready to rock and roll.
When Kev large grocery store,
well you know,
one strapped to the rank one
their belt one to their body,
you know,
anyone fighting,
they always say be first,
right?
Like maxing be first.
And that's why I ended the book with
don't be first like don't be the fucking
guy who starts shooting right away.
You know what I mean?
Because you don't want to,
don't want to be that guy.
Like,
that's not the smart move and a,
that's not the best one for survival
because people need each other like
primates in the wilderness band together.
Right?
Like the best thing,
the best survival team you can have,
the best is it is a team of experts,
right?
It is the best thing to have
in your go bag is a doctor,
a mechanic,
and a soldier.
Right.
You know,
it's like you're not going to
do all those things yourself.
Right.
So anyway,
that was kind of where I took it,
you know,
that is though it was so important.
And that was a,
also part of,
into the wilds,
he said,
he was saying that all this beautiful
wilderness that he came to love really,
he couldn't enjoy it without people.
Right.
You know,
it's one of the,
I forgot that part.
Yeah.
And that was very
profound to me because I,
I,
um,
make a lot,
I have like a little,
a bit of a dance between too many
people and not enough people.
You know,
I go,
one of the things I loved about living
in Colorado was that it was like super
quiet rural and I could be around like
virtually no one and just chill and
relax.
But I don't know if I'd
like that all the time.
I think I liked that because
I'm always dealing with
yes crowds.
No,
I love to spend half the day of myself,
but I think yeah,
if I,
I've never gone a long time.
Like I've never gone more than four or
five days without seeing people and I
think I would lose my shit.
I think I'd get pretty bummed.
I think you can easily,
are you familiar with the vice.com?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No vice guide to travel.
You're a senior.
They have to do's and don'ts.
The fashion do's and don'ts device does,
but they have a lot of
different cool things airline.
But one of them they had was a hind Moe's,
uh,
Arctic,
I think it's called
Heimos Arctic adventure.
And it's a guy named Hein Mo and he
lives up in the northeast of Alaska.
He's like one of the last people that's
allowed to like keep a cabin up there.
And it was sort of like a homesteader
group situation grandfathered in and yeah,
and this guy's been up there for,
since like the 1970s.
It's a really fascinating,
and they had these dudes from vice
magazine went up there and lived with this
guy for a week and got to see him shoot
a bear that was intruding in their,
cause he's hanging these Caribou
out in front of his camp,
but occasionally a bear
will coming to campus,
a bear ate his dog alive.
I was attached to a chain,
like really dark dark shit.
And so he's out there.
Yeah.
While he's there,
while they're there,
the guy goes out and
has to shoot this bear.
And like in the middle of the
night it's really fucked up.
Like you hear him running,
you hear guns going off,
you hear the bear moaning.
It's like really kind of fucked up.
Cause his grizzly had
founded staff once a Grizzly,
fine,
they're going to come for you.
Um,
but he was up there at one point in time.
He said,
I think for eight months
by himself and he was like,
I will never do that again.
It's like that's,
that was too much.
That was too crazy.
You have those solo sailors get into that.
They spend six months at sea by
themselves and must fuck you.
Get on it down.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You must be just so happy
to communicate with anybody.
Yeah.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't want to try it.
Um,
and you know,
now that I have a wife and kid too,
it's like,
you know,
I can't,
I'm like so codependent.
It's retarded.
Well that's one of the interesting things
about your book is that you and I are
sort of very similar in
that way that you're,
I don't want to say I felt invulnerable
cause I was always aware of my
mortality,
but I didn't worry about it
nearly as much as I started to,
once you started having children and in
your case you waited until your kid was
like fate,
basically acceptable age.
Like okay,
I'm going to the Amazon
for a little while.
I'm like,
wow.
Like,
that must've been quite a mind fuck to
be in that state of mind where you know,
you now have this baby,
that incredible love for your wife.
It's incredible lover,
her and this manly need to take care
of everything and then all of a sudden
you're in the fucking
jungle starving to death.
How long were you at it was a good idea.
I want to like six,
you know who I went to
see was Tony the Souza.
Ah,
but he would,
didn't,
wasn't there.
He actually bit,
of course he bet.
Like he ended up being somewhere else.
And Tony to Susan's an MMA
fighter or Jujitsu guys.
Uh,
a real free spirit who is,
yeah,
yeah.
I'll leave it at that.
We were going to Brazil,
we were in Brazil wants a,
me and Eddie were talking about Iowasca
and a ton of the suitors just listen to
us and he goes,
I'll fucking take that shit.
Do it.
Just do it right now.
It's like his attitude was like,
it was like,
let's do it.
So gangster now he went down,
the Amazon would like $40 or less.
You know,
just bummed is what you can do that.
And it's like sleeping outside on the
deck of the ships for months to get to
Rio.
So he came down from Peru.
Wow.
And I was like,
that sounds like that.
That would be a great trip.
But it's dangerous and crazy.
Just crazy.
You might not make it.
Yeah.
And he's,
I mean,
he looks like an India,
so he's not,
and he's not like,
oh gringo or whatever.
But so you went down a long way there.
Just six weeks.
So it wasn't there for that long.
That's a long
fucking time in the Amazon.
It was,
it was,
it was a little longer than I,
you know,
it was kind of like my old way of life.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
this will be fine.
You know what I mean?
It wasn't like I really
thought it through.
Um,
what it actually would mean.
And of course,
you know,
when you start taking care
of a kid and all that,
you know,
it becomes,
you look into the abyss,
the abyss,
listen to you write it.
Like it definitely changes you.
So I couldn't stop thinking about,
you know,
the kid and,
and you know,
my wife and not being
there if the big one hit.
And that really was the catalyst.
And then seeing how these
guys were so competent,
you know,
it's one thing to hear like,
oh yeah,
they don't want in the forest
and make whatever they need.
But then to see these guys
go and make a backpack,
like a pretty good backpack had to like,
you know,
mark and shit and just rip and it's wrong,
and,
and just catch fish and just do,
you know,
really be able to provide
easily for themselves.
I love that you,
they didn't give you a machete.
Yeah.
You realize they had sort
of infantile that you,
you're like,
you can't do anything.
You're the Gringo.
Like,
oh,
just walk with your backpack.
Don't touch shit.
You know?
And you can't get any everything.
Yeah.
Everything is with the machete.
You don't touch anything in your hand,
obviously,
because it's the jungle and
it's poisonous since thinking.
And so,
you know what a fucking crazy
place to live for six years.
And so literally everything around you
is dense and it can't touch it with your
hand because one out of how many things
is a lot of the things that boys,
but you know,
it's not like you're going to die,
it's just going to staying and swell
and what you're going to have bites.
And there's all kinds of bugs.
I don't even know what they are.
You know what's cool too is that all
the trees had a watermark on them.
And what you realize is
during the rainy season,
basically the Amazon turns into like a c,
there's dolphins swimming in the trees,
there's river dolphins swimming.
So the water comes up like 40 50 feet.
So of all of these trees is,
is a watermark for a couple,
a couple of when the rainy season,
because there's fish swimming
and dolphins in the trees.
Oh my God.
So you're walking around.
I was,
how high is the watermark
and moves around because,
you know,
but I was there in the dry season and,
and some places it was at the top
of trees and some places it was a,
you know,
it was,
it was all over the place,
but you could,
it was very clear.
So it could have been 20,
30 feet above and uh,
and they would talk about what happens
during the rainy season and how different
the landscape is because all your paths
are gone and you're in a canoe doing
everything,
walking and all the life
has to move up the tree.
So all like the poison
is answering the trees.
So it's actually more dangerous
because you bumped into a tree on
oh yeah,
it was,
it was exceeded.
It was a crazy scene.
What was the goal when you went there?
The goal?
Uh,
it was just,
uh,
you know,
I was going to do this at the time there
was a biologist who was going to come
with me and,
uh,
you know,
some local guys and there was
like an area that was unexplored.
It wasn't really unexplored,
but a bio just meant a biologist
hadn't been through there.
This is,
you know,
uh,
it was up in the Peruvian part
of the Amazon offer to Wyo,
uh,
which is a tributary and that he was
going to look around and do stuff.
So it was like kind of a
partially science thing,
but then he couldn't,
couldn't leave his job.
So it was me and just four dudes,
three dudes.
And it was like,
you know,
it's basically like going
with like three Hicks,
you know,
into the woods in Montana.
Like,
you know,
they were like,
all right,
what do you want to do?
And I'm like,
what do you guys want to do this?
We just dicked around and we
bought the raft was kind of cool.
So he just tried to survive out there.
We just hiked and survived and you know,
saw a lot of monkeys and stuff,
trail that you were
falling off the trail and,
and it was amazing.
These guys could find their way.
They map everything with the shadows.
So at mid day you don't walk anywhere
because you can't see where you're going.
So with mid day they stopped and they put
a stick in the ground and then we have
a snack and you watched a
stick and when the shadows,
okay,
now we can go again.
Ah,
yeah.
That's cool.
That's fucking,
why not bring a compass?
They're not hard to get.
I don't know.
Well yeah,
was a lot of stuff I would
have done differently.
In hindsight,
it's easy to get
green.
Hell for sure.
And what if it rains for a couple of days?
You know you're no shadows.
Yeah.
You sit under your blue
tarp and all that shit.
Wait,
yeah,
the fence.
Good for you,
Jay.
You should go.
Yeah,
I'm ready.
Sign me up.
How much weight did you lose?
A lot.
Yeah.
I mean after I'd been eating to come back,
I don't get ribbed.
I get skinnier and fatter.
That's what happens to me.
That's funny.
What did you guys eat?
We ate,
we brought,
they brought again like it was,
it wasn't a perfectly planned trip.
They told me everything was fine,
but I could have brought,
you know,
waterfall over pumps and instead I had
to boil my water the whole time cause
they were like,
oh we got it and they don't got it.
You know.
So I had to miss stop and make a little
fire to boil and then carry water and I
was carrying water and coke,
you know,
coke bottles.
Oh it was,
I didn't bring any,
you know,
any now jeans or anything like that.
Oh Jesus.
Cause they told me they had it off it,
you know,
it was all taken care of.
Yeah.
That was the idea of all taken care.
They don't care.
Just the water is there.
Like what's it like?
It was so funny.
Right.
So these guys,
they're,
they're in there basically Indio guys.
And they were like,
one of them was like,
so you've been to the ocean,
right?
I'm like,
yeah,
he's like,
it's salt water.
Right?
And I'm like,
Yup.
And he's like,
you don't drink it.
I'm like,
no,
you can't drink the salt
water cause you'll kill you.
And he kind of looked at
me like I was a pussy.
Like he was like,
hmm.
Yeah,
I mean look at you and you're like,
I can't drink the water here.
You can't ignore it there.
Like they can just drink the river water,
just drink it.
They grew up there.
What do they live to be?
20.
How old?
How old are they get?
It's crazy because some of them
there was,
uh,
the one really dangerous
thing is the snakes.
The fertile lance is like the
most poisonous snake in the world.
It's like,
you know,
turn your heart off.
What's it called?
The for the lance fern,
Lance.
It looks like a snake,
you know,
like,
uh,
I dunno if it was sneaky.
Um,
did you see one?
Yeah,
he killed one right by the camera and
I'm walking on my flip flops at night.
Right.
And they killed one
within five feet of camp.
You have to kill him cause
they're so dangerous.
And these guys all had the,
Oh yeah,
my friend got been died.
This guy didn't die,
but you know,
and we were three or four
days from a hospital.
Whoa.
So you're just,
it's luck of the draw,
you know,
with the snake will bite you.
And then sometimes it'll put a ton of
poisoning and sometimes those two a
little,
and it's sort of,
that's why some people can,
oh,
he's tough.
He survived getting bit by a rattlesnake.
I didn't,
it just didn't give them
the full dose basically.
And it could be an older
rattlesnake or it could be around,
just make that already stuck.
Something like recently,
and the babies don't have that power.
So babies are more,
they don't,
they always give a full dose.
That's why they're more dangerous.
Young rattlesnakes are the most
dangerous because they don't regulate it.
They just hit you with everything.
There's a crazy photo sort of,
um,
blog online of a guy who got bit by
a rattlesnake and then had all these
operations to,
to,
to heal the area.
[inaudible]
every time.
Yeah,
your body just rots away.
Like a lot of people don't realize,
like when that venom goes inside of you,
it doesn't just like,
oh my God,
are you going to be sick for a while?
But your arms going to run,
I'm going to damage and all this.
Yeah.
To get like all these operations and skin
grafts and shit and really scared of,
well,
the fertile and is like
a hard stop or whatever,
you know,
whatever.
I forget,
I forget what it's called,
but yeah,
it just shuts down your cardio machine.
And this is the Amazon in Peru.
Is this where you were at?
So it was in the d,
the headwaters of the Amazon in Peru.
And then there's a lot of a
bunch of the Amazons and Peru,
and that was the Amazon
is so fucking massive,
but it's incredible,
isn't it?
Like being deforested and a scary,
scary rate.
No,
it's totally,
and what was interesting
too is these guys,
so there was a,
we went to get some
fruit and they were like,
they just chop down the
tree to get the fruit right.
You know,
like they don't climb up it,
you know?
Right.
And,
uh,
you know,
I was like,
well,
isn't,
isn't that seem kind of counterpart in
their defense that the trees grow fast,
you know,
eight years it's a full tree because it's,
and they it down with the machetes.
Yeah.
But in their mind that,
you know,
it's like the jungle is endless,
like that's how they see the jungle.
And then you look at the pictures of the
fish market in Cusco and the fish used
to be six feet long and
now they're all this long.
You know what I mean?
And,
and,
and these guys wouldn't like,
they go,
oh yeah,
we have to walk farther and
farther to get the tree.
Yeah.
You cut them down and I'd like it doesn't,
you know what I mean?
Like in their heads it's limitless and
I can never be finished or whatever.
I guess the psychology of living in an,
in someplace,
I see Amazon,
it's like,
dude,
listen,
that's the last thing.
You have to worry about
this stuff going away.
The resources are endless and just
got to figure out how to stay alive.
Yeah.
Wow.
You've ever read that book
collapse by Jared diamond?
Yeah,
cause he's the guy who wrote guns,
germs and steel.
And he wrote a book about
why society fail like the,
you know,
which,
which I got into a little
bit in disaster diaries,
which was,
you know,
it's about why the Vikings had a
colony in Greenland that died out.
Or Easter Island for instance.
What happened there?
Aliens,
right?
I'm not saying it's aliens,
but why did their heads
look like that man?
Clearly.
Clearly aliens.
Is it possible you ever
watch ancient aliens?
Whenever Giorgio sucralose,
who's a good buddy?
He's been on the show a couple times,
but whenever he goes,
is it possible?
It's got to go all I know it's coming.
Oh No.
What are you going to say?
Deep flood isn't alien.
Yes.
That is possible.
It is possible.
Everything's possible.
If were possible.
If humans are possible,
virtually everything's possible.
Did they know who the
fuck was on Easter Island?
Uh,
yeah,
they,
it was these know Polynesian.
I mean that's what so let me
look at like pack rat bins,
which,
which are like these,
uh,
pack rats.
They collect stuff and they can sort
of see what's going on with the foliage
cause it kind of fossilized or whatever.
And uh,
and I,
I've eaten background by the way.
It's real.
It's delicious.
Is Delicious.
Delicious.
Really Savory is gave me
like a venison almost.
No kidding.
Where'd you get it?
I was trapping them in Kansas
and they're like little beavers.
They're not like rats.
They're like little hairy little guys.
So a pack rat is not like a week,
but does it look like
around like a big rat?
Yeah,
big hairy ran.
What's their diet?
They eat grass and
whatever they find around,
you know,
and they make these little mittens,
which,
you know what I heard mid and I'm like,
Oh,
what is it?
Like a whole number,
but it's like a little beaver lodge.
It's like a small one,
like a two foot high collection of sticks,
like in a pile.
And I learned how to make these little
dead fall traps and you put a little
peanut butter,
you know,
on the,
on the end.
And he comes in and gets under the
rock and it smashes and it kills them.
Yeah.
I've seen those dead fault traps on
like survivor man and shit like that.
It's one of those things has
come totally counterintuitive.
Like I could give you the pieces and you
would never in a million years be like,
cause it's,
it makes sense once you do it once.
That's why it's not even worth explaining.
Cause it's like I could
show you and you'd be like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I can easily do that.
But to talk about it as like a,
so the stick goes wrong.
You know,
it's simple,
but it's,
it's um,
it's tricky enough.
I'm a survivor man fan,
so I've seen that show
like a hundred times.
Yeah.
But I,
I've seen him make those.
I have no idea how to make one.
If I had to make one,
make it yourself.
All this stuff you have to
kind of do once at least,
you know,
and then you sort of,
it's like the nuclear button.
Once you know what's possible,
you can do it right.
But four minute mile,
you know,
let,
let Straub but started with
John Macpherson who is the
guy I was with in Kansas.
Oh that's how he learned.
Well one,
you know,
not only place but one of the,
he came there early on in his career and
so this guy has like an old school guy.
He's been around forever.
What we did was you trapping
pack rats a part of this book.
Yeah,
it's in there.
Yup.
Yeah.
I caught a couple rats and yeah,
just learning to do it,
you know,
and I went out every day and set up,
set up and you're in the
hot sun and you know,
it's like,
it's almost like it took me back to my
childhood and that weird way of like,
you know,
he used to like build forts for your
like Gi joes and shit in the backyard
because you don't get down and fiddle
with shit in the grass anymore.
Like that doesn't,
that's not something you do.
It's true.
And a lot of this survival stuff was
this kind of move back like a primitive,
like you have all day,
you know,
you're not doing anything else a day.
You're not fucking check in your phone.
Like you're not doing it an email.
Like you're going to make fire today
and it may take you three days,
but like you go out and,
and it's,
it's interesting to kind of get
into this other kind of time,
you know,
a sense of time and stuff like that.
It's really fun.
One of the things that high moe said,
the guy who lived a up in the Arctic or
is that he believes that the problems of
society come from the fact that we're,
we're basically at nature
hunters and gatherers.
And when we remove ourselves from
that and put ourself in the Sea of
possibilities of modern society than
100% Nigeria crazy for said it fucks us
100% okay.
So yeah,
we,
we were hunter gatherers
living in small groups.
So if the human history is a book,
right?
We were hunters and we were living in
tiny little family groups and hunting,
gathering for 200 pages of that book.
And then four paragraphs
is the modern world,
you know what I mean?
Is it's knowing for progress
is just civilization.
And then like the last sentence
is the last two centuries.
So that's how on like unequipped,
we are on an evolutionary
scale to handle cars.
You're,
you know,
running a nuclear power plant.
Twitter.
Yeah.
Twitter is the stock market,
all that shit.
Like you're just intuitively like your
gut reaction to all that shit is not
valid.
You know what I mean?
Like you,
your reaction to a person,
it's pretty good.
Like you're good at reading
people and getting like a feeling,
oh he makes me nervous.
Avoid that guy.
But uh,
the big system,
so like all those like
stock mark guys are like,
oh,
I had a feeling like you got lucky.
That's all it happened,
dude.
You know?
Yeah,
yeah.
It's a very strange situation
where obviously the world
is changing forever and
our biology is taking a long time,
can't catch up,
catch up.
And how does that work?
Does it ever catch up?
I don't think it does.
I Dunno.
Do you think that's what autism is?
Do you think that's what
a lot of diseases are?
Is that low?
The body's like scrambling to try to
figure out a way to survive this strange
time
or just random mutation and you know,
with evolution is meditation and
yeah,
an adaptation adaptation.
Due to that.
One of the things that I read about,
um,
autism was that the be
the need for emotions.
Like when we become
symbiotic with machines,
right?
That it's not going to
the need for emotions.
It's going to be essentially removed,
right?
Like we've already are like
a lot of our reward systems,
like the,
the reason why hunting and gathering
is so exciting and so fulfilling.
It's because that's what's
necessary to survive.
If you,
you've,
you've fished before,
I'm sure you know that
feeling when you catch a fish,
God and you reel it in.
Yeah,
it's very live.
You're going to live,
it's like really primal.
So it's a weird thing
when you know you've made,
you've got an animal that you
just caught and it's going to get,
provide you with sustenance is
a very strange sort of a psych.
It's goes back to your genes electric.
Yeah.
It's
very electric and it's hard to describe.
Yeah.
Um,
those jolts and those,
those positive feelings that you get
from that hunter and gatherer thing,
eventually we're not going
to need that anymore.
When you,
everything is like,
have you seen that Japanese guy that
figured out a way how to make steak out of
human feces?
Delicious,
delicious steak?
I'm not joking.
All right.
I just tweeted it.
Uh,
somebody tweeted it to me and I retweet.
It wasn't even fucking believe it is true.
Why would you even go with the steak
versus I would try like it like a risotto
first before I went right for us because
steak is meat.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know.
I'm going to touch that one.
I don't know why.
Yeah,
I don't know either.
But it's,
yeah.
Crazy though.
This,
this guy figured out a way to,
to actually make meat out of the proteins,
nutritional value left in your fees.
Well,
it's definitely like your feces is
pretty because our diets are so rich.
You're not taking all the nutritional
value out of your waste that you should
be.
Yeah,
I guess so.
If you were starving your,
your feces would be a
lot less nutritional.
But even then,
I mean,
how efficient is the human
digestive digestive tract?
I don't,
I'm just saying,
but I don't,
I don't think it's necessary to,
my shit doesn't meet out of Shit.
My Shit doesn't stink and stick.
Delicious.
I the worst thing that happened,
Joe,
one of my toilet paper rolls fell into
my toilet and then I took like the
biggest shit ever on top of it
and then I stood up and I'm like,
Oh,
what now?
I had it like you'll get it in
their old 12 members in there.
You didn't know a hole in your ass.
I just opened up the lid and it's whoever
used it before my have shut the lid
after it fell in the toilet already.
I just open up the lid and
sat down with trainspotting.
You had like dive in there,
get after that.
And then I put in an empty net,
wrap those plastic containers,
you know,
like where you put the boat wipes.
Then we had an empty one,
but it was too small and I squished it.
And all this water.
Listen,
just Google worse Google Japanese.
This is from daily tech.
Dot comes where?
Ah,
the,
the article,
Google Japanese make delicious new
nourishing steaks from human feces.
And you'll get this article.
It is really crazy.
The Tokyo sewage service in Japan
serves over 13 million people,
approximately 2000,
200 square kilometer area.
And this guy,
um,
they approached this Guy Mitch.
So Yuki Ikea,
who's a researcher from that guy.
Okay.
Yama laboratory and their ideas,
they,
the problem is they
had too much sewer mud,
also known as a shouldn't human excrement.
Okay.
And so the excrement is a breeding
ground for scores of bacteria.
So this guy came up with this crazy
idea to make food out of that.
No Way.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
in a way it's good,
right?
Because we're going to have food problem,
you know?
And if we could recycle everything,
if we could recycle,
you know,
hey,
let's do it.
You know,
I don't get it.
The first idea is what the guy does.
The first step is they cook the
bacteria and it kills the bacteria.
And then they extract their
proteins via separation technique.
Right.
And Soy protein is added
to enhance the flavor.
That's how you know
that it tastes terrible.
Let's make your food tastes better.
It's better because you're
eating shit and Tofa.
Oh,
that's a tough one.
Yeah.
It's even finished with a red food
color to give it a comforting,
whew.
Well,
you know,
they die.
Mcdonald's dies their meat to make
it a blessing to be translucent,
translucent.
Well,
it's so fatty.
Really?
Is that what it is?
They have put up these
hamburger meat diets.
I mean,
I don't know.
It's,
that's,
it could be an urban myth.
I could be wrong.
Could be,
you've gotta be careful.
I know.
It'd be so many Snopes that,
um,
there's a,
a website,
I forgot what the website is,
where they take a cheeseburger
from Mcdonald's and they
just let it or a handle
on what happened.
Let it sit out and it fucking never rots.
So shelf life is
like a twinkie.
Yeah.
Maybe if she'd go to the radio,
carbon dating and isotopes and like if
you know that twinkie shirts and big
back,
it's actually the Twinkies
don't last forever.
And it's just a myth,
I believe.
Don't know.
How long do they last?
Like I think it's a couple of months
after or a month or something like that.
After the,
there's a,
the sugar goes off.
Why didn't you try?
Because you had some of
the last 25 to take one.
Put It on your desk if
you're under 100 donors.
Yeah.
Take one and put it on a plate and see if,
uh,
and then find that whole thing.
By the way,
I would have you started buying it if
you guys got into nine and yet what does
that mean?
Vine is a program that
Twitter just buy it.
You remember about a year ago,
somebody on one of these podcasts ask,
what do you think's next?
What's the next Twitter?
And I said video,
Twitter.
It's pretty much what it is.
And so what it is is Twitter just bought
this company called vine and it's like
seven seconds of video
and you just pretty much,
you can just do seven seconds or
you could do like stop motion.
All right,
so hold on.
Seven seconds.
Is this ready?
Go Dude Dude,
dude,
that's not enough.
That's enough time to do something stupid.
Yeah.
And but what's cool is that it
loops it but like an animated Gif.
So everyone's making
pretty much animated gifts,
but it does it with the sound.
So how many of them are just girls
asked is about growing up in the horn,
of course is leading the way in and
six seconds is all you need for more.
Are you allowed to have porn on Twitter?
Cause some girls do.
Like sometimes you go to their profile
and all of sudden it's a cock in her
mouth.
It's just because they haven't been found.
Wow.
There's a lot of them out there.
There's pretty lacks.
Some of the best people though is Brody.
Brody is fucking hilarious
at the divine for.
It's just like pretty much got big in
the last couple of weeks and now it's
blowing the fuck up.
Or I'll show you some.
That's fascinating man.
And what it does is it just
loops the brave new world.
Well,
it's,
that's know.
I have not seen any,
I've heard the backed of our strange,
strange fucking wacky culture where we're,
we're getting more and
more ink interconnected,
giving people a little seven
seconds glimpse to your life,
you know,
over and over and over again.
Right.
It's weird stuff to prepare for.
It's like they're there.
The real question is,
what's next?
And are these instincts and all the,
these hunting and gas,
are they holding us back or is
it inevitable that things change?
Is it good that they change?
Well,
I mean,
the question really comes,
I think,
you know,
they're not going to
change unless there's a,
an,
you know,
an evolutionary advantage.
Unless they're selected out.
Like,
yeah,
people are always like,
oh,
your pinky toe is gonna disappear.
No,
it's not.
Not unless it's like,
unless guys without the pinky toe are
really like really good looking and have a
lot of kids.
You know what I mean?
There's got to be right and
evolutionary pressure for that change.
So I kind of feel like we've removed
all the evolutionary pressures because
we've created the perfect
environment for ourselves.
You know,
and there's a lot of guys
that are smarter than me.
They talk about,
there still are subtle pressures of work.
It's just,
I don't know what they are.
It's just not the same sort of pressures
that exist in the natural world.
We spent at all created
these contained environments.
These cities were perfectly
suited for this environment.
It's very strange and it's,
uh,
it's so confusing because as science
advances and he gets to the point where
they have nanotechnology to keep your
body alive and eat all the cancers in you
and you're going to be able
to genetically engineer you.
So you look like a super athlete and
they're going to be able to change your
mind and make you symbiotically
connected to electronics.
Put Google in your brain.
I mean Google glasses is just right now.
It's,
you wear it well how long
before it's an insert,
plug it in.
I mean when is it going
to be a contact lens?
Cause they're also considering
that they're considering
contact lenses that show
you information on the Lens,
right?
Like some sort of a
Bluetooth or something.
Contact Lens.
Will they be able to
communicate wirelessly and
you'll see fucking images on
your eyes when you know how long,
but when,
when does that,
when is that going to be a reality?
When I was assistant to a
story on NPR about robotics,
like taking over,
you know,
Blah Blah,
blah,
that old story about,
you know,
and you,
and you wonder if there are certain point
where it's just cheaper to get people
to do it because people were cheaper.
You know what I mean?
Like isn't it at some
point but exponential.
Yeah.
Well that's true,
right?
Especially in the real issue with
certain countries don't value human life.
There's this countries where and then
it's always the countries that have the
most people.
Right?
So it's like what you hear
about human rights violations.
Like China's like a real tricky one when
it comes to like factory workers and
she's just so God damn anything.
What are you going to sort of,
what are you showing me?
The vine.
That's what it is.
It's just like a quick animation thing
and it just has like sometimes it has
sound,
sometimes it doesn't,
but it's caught on to the point.
Everybody is fucking doing it right now.
WHO's everybody?
I'm not like you're not doing it.
Look at Twitter.
Have you done it?
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm all over.
When did you start doing it?
About four days ago.
How can people find you
on it?
You just started doing it and you're just
making little videos like just for fun
or like ever since it came out I'm
already not even using Instagram anymore.
It's good.
You jump on it right now and people
are getting really good at it.
Like a will.
Sasso is really funny.
Add it and you could become
the next Twitter champ.
A chess master.
He started right now.
I wonder where it ends.
I just started tweeting,
finally fucking got ahold of it somehow.
How come you can't Kid Sam Sheridan?
What's the,
I dunno,
I just don't have that fighters.
I probably could.
I don't know
who Sam Sherman.
Because you've got a new book out man.
Call.
Call it a fighter's mind.
Your new book is disaster diary.
Just as confusing as fuck man.
At one point.
But I am doing it.
I am.
I,
it's funny that I was talking to a
guy who works there and he's like,
yeah,
it just clicks for people at some point.
Twitter.
And then it finally clicked
for me a little bit.
Oh,
Twitter is amazing.
You know what's the most amazing thing
for me is retweeting things again,
cool shit that people send
me and then retweeted them.
Yeah.
It's um,
between um,
Matt stags,
my publicist,
he sends me three times a day,
the nuttiest shit that he finds on
the Internet as part of like his gig.
And,
um,
between that and the shit that
I get from dudes on Twitter,
it's amazing the access to new
ideas and stories you have,
the Av,
that change is one of the biggest changes
in human culture over the last hundred
years.
What are you doing Bryan?
I'm finding it,
finding that do a dance,
do a dance change is one of
the biggest changes in a,
in human culture.
I think it's,
well,
she had the ubiquity of information,
you know,
you can get stuff,
you can know everything.
You can be in India,
in India,
and get all the information that
we can get right here and all that.
Yeah.
As long as there's some sort of a
connection to your phone or some sort of,
even a fucking two g,
you know,
if you're in some shitty country,
just take a little slower,
but you're still gonna be able
to connect to the database.
And now,
especially with Google
answers for questions,
just at your service.
Yeah.
Right there.
It's fucking drag out tracking.
You watch it everything.
But who's tracking who are,
what are they going to do and how can,
yeah.
That's what I feel like tracking them too.
There's so much information.
Like you feel free to track my,
well I think it's really interesting
that people are really concerned with
privacy as they should be and they're
really concerned with the government
interfering with their
privacy as they should be.
But the fucking head
of the CIA got Boston.
Right.
That's what's fascinating to me.
It's like,
by the way,
you're not in all your
emails are all online.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
who is the head of the spooks.
Okay.
The FBI goes and investigates him and
it's all there if you can't get away.
And not only that,
but like what a bunch of fucking condoms.
They weren't willing to like look away.
Like they wanted to bring
that out in the open.
The eye doesn't like the CIA.
Like isn't that crazy?
You would think that
everyone is in the same team.
You know the FBI,
the CIA during the same team.
I feel like they're not.
There's some probably so much gets
fucked up I pissing contest and you never
even know about like
major diplomacy like this,
you know like the head of
this and that and like,
oh I got the wrong
chair funk this meeting.
You know what I mean?
And like they walk in and like
we don't know why we're at war.
That's cause that guy got the wrong chair.
Hey you,
why am I on the corner of the table?
Don't respect me.
Yeah.
I shouldn't be at the head of the
table and my chat should be gold dot.
Yeah,
there's a,
you don't even know the pissing contest
is that fact that the FBI doesn't get
along with the CIA.
I'm like,
you motherfucker.
How do you expect me to be patriotic when
you contour running the whole military
industrial complex are going
after each other and over pussy.
Okay.
It's not worth Patraeus Pussy.
Well it's not though.
That was a thing though.
It was also about Libya.
It was about Bengazi.
It was also about them attacking
like the way it was handled.
The,
the tacking of the U s embassy apparently.
And that was part of the whole scandal
that went down was they felt like they
did a poor job of handling that whole
attack on the US embassy and somehow or
another it's connected.
I don't know how we,
civilians will probably
never know exactly what,
probably more professor who,
you know,
it's just pedestrian
and boring people just,
I don't know why it's all about puts it,
but it's all about the fact
that there's no privacy anymore,
you know?
Yeah.
And everything is recorded and I'm going,
of course you've seen all the
videos of the media right across,
say wild,
right.
You know what I found out the Russians
have a lot of dash cams because of
insurance fraud because the Russian people
just fucking slam on the brakes or in
front of it.
You hit to me
named sue you.
Um,
apparently it's super dominant.
Russian Russians drive.
So bananas.
And you ever seen some of
the Russian dragon videos?
I think I tweeted about it or
talking about it or something.
W rushing driving videos
are fucking horrible.
They're amazing.
They are animals.
There's two types of really
loony driving videos out there.
I don't want to generalize,
but I'm Gunna two types.
The Chinese,
which we've had on the show before,
and Russians,
Chinese for being fucking
completely clueless.
Like someone told me,
and I don't know if it's
just showing it retro,
but it's not racial,
it's,
it's more racial than racist,
but what it is is that the culture,
the Chinese culture,
because there are so many people
interacting with each other that they're
comfortable bumping into each other.
It's a part of the normal
culture population's so big
and you just get used to
it.
And if you're in Asia,
like you have to accept that
like this is the way they are.
They're not being rude.
It's just pumping into,
it was kind of like that.
You've been there,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I didn't find that in Tokyo.
I found them to be very polite,
but apparently China,
you're,
you're right,
it's thick,
high density population.
People are touching you.
But the idea is that they're used to
looking straight ahead and not looking to
the left and looking to the
right and their culture also
rewards or sort of encourages mining your
own fucking business and keeping your
eyes on yourself,
not paying attention and not wandering
around and undisciplined gates.
Well that sort of applies.
They're driving,
they have blinders on and they just sort
of go where they were trying to go and
mention this.
This sort of way of looking at the world
does not work when you're dealing with
cars.
When you're sober you
have to avoid traffic and
brings it right back to my book,
which is really Nice because situational
awareness was one of the things I
really got into.
And situational awareness is exactly that.
Like paying attention to your surroundings
and it's a huge survival trait.
You know,
it's like the military train it,
they talk about essay all the time,
training your essay and they do things.
But you know,
it's that natural thing like
you do in a parking lot,
right?
Cause you're,
you know,
you're not in the freeway,
you're kind of space out,
listen to music.
But in a parking lot,
you're,
you know what's going on and you're
creeping around and your situation and
where,
you know,
that's kind of the difference.
And your book also covered how important
one little mistake can be in a critical
situation.
Like especially in a fire,
you were talking about,
you spent a lot of time fighting forest
fires and how you go left when you
should've gone.
Right and you're fucked.
You're trapped.
And,
and,
and the only way to find
out is to make that mistake.
Yeah.
What did he say?
Like,
you know,
fire like a lot of things,
but fire supplies the test
first and then less than second.
Right.
You know,
which is so you,
you,
you get tested and then afterwards they
go back and they break down all the
things you did wrong or did right.
And you,
everybody else can learn the lesson,
but at the time you just get
tested and it's pass fail.
Like you live or die.
And it's just,
and that's kind of the way
fire wildland fire has been.
And,
and,
uh,
we go back and we studied tragedy fires
where people died like a 30 mile or a
storm King.
And there's a lot of those names,
but you sort of break it
down scientifically what
they did wrong when it's
barely,
you know,
hindsight's 20,
20,
it totally easy.
But at the time,
you know,
I don't feel like these,
I really want to hear about how those,
the cops looking for Dorney a,
uh,
shot up the hood of the cars.
You know what I mean?
I really want to kind of,
you know,
that's the kind of thing I'm
interested in explaining that story,
but people don't know.
So there was this been this
huge manhunt in La and um,
it's Dorner is it Charles Dorner?
Ll Cool J.
Yeah,
he looks a lot like ll
cool j a fat ll cool.
J and J is huge by the
[inaudible] 70 and not fat,
like pretty bulky,
strong after looking dude.
And uh,
it was,
you know,
he was like,
ex ex military and very dangerous.
And he wrote this rant on Facebook and
killed some cops and they finally tracked
him down.
But yeah,
kill the cops.
Family too.
Is Dot her daughter and her husband,
he really,
yeah,
he killed a cop's
daughter and her husband,
um,
you know that the guy who was
representing him at the trial the same,
right?
Yeah,
he was,
he was very,
uh,
bitter about it.
Know about this by the way.
Oh,
a lot of people don't know the story,
man.
A lot of people don't know who,
what the name was.
Trusted him.
Everyone's like,
oh,
Jay,
not necessarily.
It may mean there's a
lot of people are sort
of vaguely aware of it,
but,
but the La people don't know
about the cop shooting up the car.
They shot up this,
they show up two cars,
they shut up two different colored,
you know,
again,
it was dawn.
So color,
you know,
everything's monochromatic.
It don't,
it's hard to see color.
So I don't blame him for that.
But they shot up a car with
two Mexican old ladies in it.
So they will do it,
deliver newspapers,
newspapers at 4:00 AM.
And they shot them,
they shot them,
and then they shut up at surfer.
I've got white guy in his
truck and nobody died.
They don't think they hit the other guy.
They shot on his truck up.
But so you wonder how
trigger happy they are.
And of course LAPD has
terrible reputation.
Yeah.
Um,
but also you sort of see,
you know,
it's like very,
it's there.
People are still people,
they're still human and you
see what stress does to people,
you know,
and you see shit that's not there and you,
it's,
it's this sort of amazing,
I'd love to kind of see the after
action reports they come up with,
you know,
ask the people to get out of the car,
put their hands up or so I
think they started moving.
Yeah.
I think one of the cars,
they even just rammed it.
So they just started shooting.
That's the mother fucker.
Yup.
That's him.
Boom.
And like,
you know,
it's,
it's like confirmation
bias and all that shit.
You know what I mean?
Like you so scary having
people in payroll,
people being in control is so dangerous.
And cops,
you know,
the truth is,
people talk to me about
firearms a little bit.
You know,
cause I spent about three
weeks straight training farms.
It's one of the best firearms
instructors in the country.
This guy,
tiger monkey and Alabama.
And you know,
you have to train your ass off to use
a gun successfully in an altercation.
Like because of what we've talked about,
this stress,
what stress does to you,
you know,
and cops,
the most police,
you know,
they,
they have the budget to train,
you know,
a couple of days a year
and they never get a train,
you know,
hand to hand.
So they,
they,
they really don't get
paid enough to shoot.
Swat team guys are different and
they get paid to shoot enough,
you know,
and ammunitions expensive and blah blah.
But even cops,
like they just don't shoot enough,
you know.
So like the idea of arming teachers is
fine as long as you're going to pay for
them to train and train a lot.
They going to train every month.
Yeah,
they're going to be part of their life
or they're not going to be able to do it
and it's not going to work.
You know?
It's pointless.
It's more dangerous because
then you have guns around.
Someone else can tell me there was,
I don't know,
whatever,
but it's like it's just you.
This is a fact,
like you have to train your ass off with
a weapon with a firearm because again,
it's,
it's complex motor skills.
It's not intuitive and even that doesn't
guarantee that you're going to be able
to perform under stressful situations.
How do you condition yourself to
perform under stressful situations?
Like what is,
if you were going,
it's like say,
okay look,
it's what the number 10 let's put,
let's pretend the end
of the world is coming.
Some Sheridan has his own branch
and the Sam Sheraton ranch,
you're going to figure out a way to train,
train people how to do.
You're going to come.
And that's what the military does.
So you do as much as you can in terms of,
you know,
loud noises,
a smoke,
uh,
you know,
fear,
unexpected things happening and you know,
and,
and realistically recreate these scenes.
You know,
they find when people are
shooting at human targets,
the targets,
even silhouettes that
looked like a person,
they're much better at killing people
in battle then if they're shooting it at
just the crosshairs or just to Bullseye.
Hmm.
So you'd have to condition,
you know,
that's what they have.
All those houses that they walk
through and you train and train.
That's what Swat teams do.
And Swat teams do great.
You know,
because they train and train
and train and train and train,
and then they can,
they can execute it,
you know?
And also swat members,
they're probably been on a few of those.
By the time he gets to a
certain point in their career,
you know,
it's not his first,
he's on these a lot of times and,
and,
and even those guys,
they can get so hyped up
that they make mistakes,
you know?
And it happens.
And the tiger was telling me that like,
there was a police,
uh,
house to walk through it,
you know,
for a shooting.
And there was a,
uh,
you know,
a four foot by four foot bullet
trap that was behind the target.
So there's a target,
you know,
like a person and they walked to the
door and they have to draw and shoot this
thing and guys are missing the
trap from like six feet away.
Whoa.
So they're just going,
Eh,
and they're shooting into
the air or the shooting,
you know,
and these are cops,
you know what I mean?
It's not you and me who was never like,
oh,
ah,
you know what I mean?
It's like they,
they,
and,
and this whole thing about the
knife being better than the gun.
You ever hear that one?
No.
So the,
so,
uh,
there's a thing called the,
the taller rule,
the Tula rule,
which is a,
a cop in Vegas in the 80s,
um,
started timing,
uh,
how long it would take for a guy to cut
you with a knife before you could hold
on holster and get your gun
out and present and shoot him.
And he found that from 21 feet or less,
he was going to get you before
you could get a shot off.
Oh,
so they call it the 21 foot rule.
So if a guy has a knife
and he's closer in 21 feet,
you got to shoot him.
Or you know,
you think you think all the guns better,
I want a gun.
But actually because it's,
it doesn't jam,
it doesn't screw up.
It's not fine motor skill.
This is not a fine motor skill,
right?
This is,
this is,
this is simple.
You know how to do this.
You're born,
you're going to die.
No one had a hit somebody with
a knife and it never goes away.
Even how stressed you are.
So that's one of the reasons why they
actually say a knife is better than the
gun in a lot of situations is corrected.
A huge,
I did a long training
session of knife fighting,
which is,
I'm want to get nightmare nightmares,
dude.
Nightmares.
It's terrible.
What happens once you
start getting intellect?
The awfulness of getting cut open.
Yeah.
It's an awful [inaudible] Jujitsu,
you know?
It's like I have a knife.
Good luck.
It doesn't matte black belt.
I'm just,
it's like,
it just starts going and you never,
you can't turn it off.
It's like,
it just keeps going.
As long as it's sharp,
you know?
It's easy.
Yeah.
It's terrible.
Collin and I talked about that
when we came to butchering a deer.
Like though the reality of questions,
it opens up.
Yeah.
With this razor knife protein.
Flesh just sorta separates.
Yeah.
It's not difficult to separate
the essential parts of your body.
It's like an uncooked egg.
Yeah.
It's not like a hard boiled egg.
It's like,
that's what your skin and flesh
like and that's what these knife,
the knife stuff is about you.
Like you don't like,
I don't like,
you know,
so you've,
you've punched me.
I don't just cut your arm and I like that.
I go and I shave,
you know,
a huge slap a skin off your arm and
now think now what are you doing?
Like now your mind is your,
yeah,
you're not thinking about me anymore.
Yeah,
you're not,
you know.
Well they also say that some of the knife,
it's very easy for them to punch you in
the face because you're so concentrated
on that knife that kick you in
the balls and punch in the face.
Like you,
you really focused on it.
You won't even stop it.
We used to do like spark,
like last part with like these little um,
uh,
like stun blades,
blades.
It's got like a little shock to it.
Like it's,
you know,
it's like a bee sting,
um,
shocking electric shock knife.
Yeah.
Cause he ain't company makes him,
yeah,
yeah.
And the crackle and they,
they crack the crackling is almost
scarier because you're like,
cause it's,
it's like the sound,
it sounds like a light saber or something,
you know,
it's like a beast thing.
You're like,
oh,
that's not that big a deal.
But it's the idea that
you just got chopped.
And uh,
I was doing it in fighting,
you know,
and whatever.
And the worst is when you
don't have a knife and he does,
this is just the lambs to slaughter dude.
You're like,
you're hyperventilating.
Like trying to time the jump,
like got something like God,
I'm down.
I took his back and I had the knife in
one hand and I was trying to get the
choke in and it was like I had to let
it go because I couldn't hold that knife
with one.
Actually I think I had the knife and he
was going to take it away from me and I
started choking him cause I'm like,
oh,
they'll give them something to think.
And like I had,
I couldn't,
I had to stay with that knife because
it was so devastating that the choke was
like,
he's like,
he doesn't give a shit.
He can because he knows it's not,
I can't get them in,
you know,
15 seconds.
He's going to have the knife
and he's going to start,
you know,
what are the,
uh,
did you like,
do like a,
when you have a knife fight in class,
do you use a rubber ninth?
Yeah.
You do rubber knives,
real knives too,
just to kind of have
techniques that you love.
Yeah,
yeah.
One of disagreement,
you know,
so it's a lot of it's from Filipino
stick fighting and the Philippines is
famously the place where,
you know,
this was like an art form
and they were invaded by,
uh,
all kinds of sorted people so that
the Spaniards came and the Portuguese
invaded.
And then the Japanese came with,
so they,
they've been exposed to
all these styles and,
uh,
the,
the name and it's like,
I think Palau is that people have a knife.
So,
you know,
it's very,
a part of their culture.
And also they were enslaved for 300 years.
You know what I mean?
They were longer than
America's been a country.
They were a colony of Spain and
then the u s and all that stuff.
So they've got that in their system.
And then so they've really turned
knife fighting into a high art.
And I love it.
And you scream was really fun.
I actually got really into it.
Does it scream
out or Filipino arts?
Do they have any,
uh,
striking arms?
Yeah,
well they do a boxing thing and,
and,
and um,
you know,
people talk about Manny Pacquiao doing,
what is it that it was a call,
I don't know,
but it's,
it's part of a screen.
But basically it's all part of this.
And the screen was even a Spanish word,
you know,
and people,
I think there's,
um,
a Filipino movements that
kind of reclaimed the art.
But the arts,
the whole nature of,
it's very democratic.
Like it comes from everywhere and it's
got all kinds of different terms and it's
very,
it's very,
it's very inclusive.
I'm not,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but were the Philippines created by
Chinese and Spaniards getting together?
Isn't that like,
yeah,
it was a Spanish colony for a long time
and they were invaded by everybody.
Like they,
you know,
they were islanders.
It was,
you know,
Micronesia,
whatever stuff.
And that's the real fucking problem,
man.
That's what we've sort of limited more
than ever before is people invading
people just taking over their land.
We've sort of,
that's slowed down quite a bit
still going on when we're doing it.
But like if you look at like what
you used to have to deal with,
like most of the world,
but it's like sitting down,
man,
I hope nobody shows up.
Yeah.
Somebody showed up dead.
It wasn't like if you were
an American you could just,
well there was no Americans obviously,
but if you were an Irishman,
you could just say all the way to Fiji,
they would eat you.
Yeah.
You know,
you couldn't just show up and
Bornea they would fucking kill.
You know,
they talk about how dangerous,
uh,
in Papa New Guinea,
they,
there are people that hadn't
been contacted and they
talk about how dangerous
strangers are.
Like,
it's so dangerous to meet new people.
It's like everybody is on red alert.
What did you hear about that,
those fishermen that were killed recently?
No.
Yeah,
the one of the last uncontacted
tribe did day and these people,
they,
they fucked up and they wound up a short,
they were drunk and they
were in a fishing boat.
I think it's,
I,
I want to say New Guinea,
some left.
Apparently there's something
Central America and South America.
I mean,
there's killed New Guinea.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the story was that they,
they had gotten drunk and they washed
up on the shore in the wrong place.
Yeah.
They,
they,
they fucked up and these
people were there and uh,
they just fucking,
they killed him,
man.
Yeah.
And that,
this,
this one uncontacted tribe.
Yeah.
They don't,
and they have to wait until they
want to retrieve the bodies,
but they have to wait until these people
move to the other side of the island.
These natives because
if they go over there,
they're going to have to kill them.
And they're the,
like the last of these tribes and these,
uh,
these poor drunk fishermen just fucked
up and drifted a shore and they just
jacked him.
Yeah.
And again,
that goes back to like,
what's most of human history,
Ben?
That,
yeah.
I mean not this modern thing where you
get in the subway and there's people you
don't know right behind you.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Or that you don't even speak their
language and you're staying at the four
season and it's file and then,
you know,
and they're cleaning your room.
Well,
you are,
it's a weird,
or whatever,
any hotel,
but it'd be even crazier.
How about,
you know,
you go to one of those things that,
uh,
students do.
What do they stay at those,
uh,
the hostels,
dorm room fill you of other people that
speak a language you don't understand
you're sleeping together.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's a modern society.
Yeah.
It's fascinating.
And so in that sense,
it's much safer now than ever before,
but that could all erode
immediately with one astro.
Yeah.
No,
there was a great,
uh,
hold on,
let me just,
talking about the asteroids,
did you,
do you follow at all?
Um,
like,
uh,
the,
the history of asteroidal
impacts or a little bit,
a little bit.
I mean,
I'm kind of this actually have a,
yeah,
not Clovis,
but I actually,
you know,
a little bit,
I'm into it,
you know what I mean?
That's cool.
Yeah.
Did you see the new thing that the
Russian scientists are Russian astronomers
have found?
They believe there's one that's
going to hit 93 years from now?
No,
it's,
yeah,
they think they found one
that's a real motherfucker.
Right.
That's going to hit that
Russian shit was scary.
Yes,
it was awesome.
I loved it.
I explained to people that might not have,
you know,
make getting up later.
Um,
the rush we're talking about
Russian media or impacts the,
the video footage,
uh,
that we were talking about
earlier with the cams,
the video cams,
these people than their dash cams,
the one where it hit and it's like,
boom.
Right.
It was brighter than the
sun for a second half.
Fuck,
flash hit.
Let me,
let me read you this.
So this is what,
so there's,
I think there's about a thousand a year
of these little ones and then then the,
the rock of one third of a meter across
explodes with the a hundred tons of
dynamite.
And that happens 40 times a year,
three meters across the rock hits
with a force of 2000 tons of dynamite.
Oh my God.
And 30 meters,
it's now an asteroid.
And then if it,
if it hits its 2 million tons of dynamite
were flat and everything was in six
miles at a hundred meters and asteroid
is the equivalent of 80 million tons of
diamond light.
And that was what hit
in 1908 and flattened,
you know,
1200 miles of the forest in Siberia.
Is that,
that proven that a,
that's Tom Guskey right?
You go school.
Yes.
And you know that for a fact?
Well I think so.
And then,
and a half mile across the
crater is nine miles wide.
A fireball that is 25 times larger than
the sun and it's a 7.8 earthquake when
it hits and would cause nuclear
winter and in civilization,
Oh my God.
But the species would survive.
Then the next biggest one
up a six miles across plus,
uh,
is the end of everything.
And that's like what
happened to the dinosaurs.
Right.
It gets in that like how it just
starts like flickering like it.
Like it's like a flicker almost.
Yeah.
And that's a little baby.
This little baby I've had
that I've seen one really,
really close up once.
I seen one that here
in Calabasas died out.
Yeah.
Like a shit what you call a shooting star.
And there was apparently one that
was filmed in San Francisco as well.
Yeah.
And these have nothing to do with that.
Other Astra has two really close
by to 41 or inside the outer ring of Sal.
It's awesome.
That's how close this fucking thing is.
And that one is a motherfucker.
If that one hits us,
look at all this damage.
This thing.
Yeah.
That was a big one.
The one that came.
This was crazy.
Just how it looks.
It looks like almost like a filter,
right?
Instagram.
Yeah,
look at that.
It just brightens the whole thing.
It's amazing that everybody
likes swerved off the road.
Everybody's like,
dude to do.
Yeah.
There's a good compilation
at live leak right now.
It has all of them in one long video.
Yeah.
This is strange times where
we get to document this.
I know.
Whereas before if this happened,
it would just be mean.
We wouldn't even hear it.
Oh,
a thing about it.
Yeah.
We would have no idea that this even
happened in Russia just 10 years ago.
Yeah.
And I think that actually really
does contribute to the paranoia.
Sure.
Cause like you've seen the footage
now of the tsunami and Fukushima,
like you can't,
you can't get away from it.
You know,
and the,
and the nine 11 you've seen that
come down a million times and this,
it's just,
it's,
it makes you,
it's like you'd like to think
you're sophisticated and,
and that you don't believe in advertising
and that that shit doesn't affect you.
But the truth is like you're very simple.
You're an animal and
that shit works on you.
You know,
and you believe that
life is a Sandra Bullock movie.
Meanwhile,
Sandra Bullock,
he'd be like,
she's great rocks come from the
fucking sky and drop on things.
Ooh,
there was,
um,
there's a,
uh,
an area,
um,
in time about 13,000 years ago that I'm
fascinated by because I've been reading
all this stuff about this,
what it looks like,
nuclear class,
this green glass they found all over the,
uh,
the earth and about 13,000 years and
they think it was a series of meteor
impacts about 13,000 years ago,
all over the globe.
Oh Wow.
They found this stuff.
It's really cool.
They've found like big people
were around for that stuff.
And there's oral history.
Oh yeah.
Well that's,
that's what they think is,
you know,
the,
the ancient history theorists that
follow sort of an alternative timeline.
Right.
I believe that there's been some rises
and falls and that accounts for Atlanta
and a lot of different,
well the men
dry and then you know,
that broken the Atlantic
went in and flooded it.
Well,
there's a bunch of,
I mean I'm sure there's been a
series of cataclysmic disasters,
but they're just coming to terms now with
this proliferation of this green glass
all over the earth at
about 13,000 years ago.
So it was enough to kill a lot of
fucking people wipe out a lot of shit,
but not enough to kill everybody and,
and burn it into the collective
unconscious of this can happen.
But this,
these impacts that we saw a hertz,
400 people,
they didn't leave behind any of
this green shit as far as I know.
Yeah.
It depends on,
I mean,
there's probably much bigger,
what you're talking about,
this stuff was the same stuff that is,
um,
created when you have nuclear tests.
Oh,
right.
It's sort of green.
Super Glad,
right?
Yeah.
We're rock is just bull
asked to buy this impossible force,
but apparently it's all
over the world at 13,000 or
something.
Fucked us sideways just and it,
it also coincides with
the end of the ice age.
Right.
Which it might've been.
That might've changed the climate.
Sure,
sure.
It's really some crazy shit.
Well,
yeah,
we wouldn't be surprised at all.
Yeah.
They also think that it might have
something to do with some of the mass
extinctions that went on during that time.
There's a lot of confusion as to like
what happens to the wooly mammoths and you
have to think anymore men
hunted them out or you know.
Yeah.
But I've heard that,
that there's a lot of people that say,
well that's crazy what you're talking
about guys with spears and they're,
they're hunting out there.
They're going to,
you're going to wipe
out these motherfuckers.
Really?
Yeah,
I know.
I don't know.
I'm not,
yeah,
I dunno.
I'm pointing to,
right.
I've heard asteroids of her other things,
but it's weird to think that
this society we have now,
which seems so permanently here we are
place talking through wires that are
connected to the Internet,
whatever the fuck that is and sends
this audio file out to a million people.
But the think that this could
all go away and you trap,
it's an hack rats with rocks.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's sort of funny because you never,
you don't think it's going to happen
and you don't think it's possible.
It's like a,
it's a little bit like being on the
freeway where you don't think an accident.
It's impossible.
Like it sort of feels like it
can never happen and you know,
and then shit happens.
And,
and uh,
it's,
it's like a,
you know,
in California,
earthquake insurance gets,
you know,
it's expensive right after the earthquake
and then it gets cheaper and cheaper
and cheaper because it,
but actually the danger is going up,
right.
The risk is,
you know,
but,
but if people are buying it,
you forget,
you know?
Yeah.
People aren't buying it and it's,
it's,
uh,
this is human nature.
We're were simpler.
There's like,
you know,
it's a myth that man is a rational actor.
You're an emotional actor
and you rationalize it.
You know,
like we're trying,
we're trying to figure out how to
rationally quantify bounded rationality in
humans too.
Yeah,
no,
totally.
The idea that we have access to the
events that take place in the lives of
billions of people.
It's just too nutty.
It's like,
how are we supposed to pay attention
to all these different events,
animal attacks and meteors and sharks
and fucking all this shit is happening
because you're dealing with an insane
number of human beings and insane number
of lives.
Totally.
So if you look at life,
I mean I think we're probably
way safer than ever before,
but we're also way more fucking paranoid.
Yes.
We're taking into account shit that's
happening to people that are impossibly
far away.
Yeah,
exactly.
They actually agree 100% and you know,
it's,
it's all one of the safest times to be.
It's certainly be American
live here in the first world.
And yet,
you know,
reporting,
being human nature,
we're drawn to scary stories and
we're drawn to the shark attack.
Even though you know,
you're much more look to get fat
and die of diabetes that you know,
that's what's going to
get you a car accident.
But you're worried about sharks.
Well,
I think our biggest fear today,
the most likely fear is human sabotage.
And what by by human sabotage,
I mean like man created issues
like car accidents or drugs or,
or,
you know,
things along those lines.
Like,
do you know how many fucking people that
I've talked to who have kids that are
hooked on pills?
Right?
I mean apparently in high schools today
it is a big shuttle in is like drug
dealing.
Ritalin is like a whole
and Adderall is a big one.
Oxycontin's are big.
I heard about a lot of writers use it.
Yeah.
Adderall to write their stuff
like screenplays and stuff.
I hear the screenwriters to it
and here's the danger to that,
which I think my ex lane what's happening.
But there's um,
Jonah Lehrer wrote that book
called imagine about how
innovation works and he's
been,
you know,
he's the guy who got discredited
cause he made up Bob Dylan quotes.
He did.
Oh yeah,
I heard about that totally.
Yet he got,
but the book is actually not bad and
that it was too bad that he do that.
It's not even interesting.
Like,
it's not even the good part of the book.
I don't know what,
what happened?
I think he's pretty arrogant dude.
But the um,
the,
the thing about innovation is it
like caffeine hurts her innovation.
Adderall hurts your innovation.
Like it helps you focus,
but you innovation needs
to be broad with your mind.
That's why it happens in the shower.
That's what happens in your own
walks or you're kind of spacing out.
You got,
and you made me tired sometimes.
Yeah.
Your brain makes a connection.
It wouldn't have made otherwise.
It's reaching through your all
your experience and it's going,
oh look at this would have
worked if you just thought of it.
But you can't when you're
on Adderall and cat,
even caffeine,
you can't do that because
you're focusing focusing.
Right.
That's why coke people
are so hard to talk to.
Yeah.
Certainly.
Specific Coke people and
some people they don't,
they're not like abstract
or fascinating at all.
They're just real linear and obvious and
repetitive and boring and you're like,
Oh man,
get me out of this.
Well,
some people I do find with coke,
like they feel like they're the king of
the world and that's the people that you
have to watch out.
And Caffeine can also have that
same sort of euphoric chatterbox.
It's why I love it.
Yeah.
I love coffee,
caffeine.
But I think that as far
as like stimulants go,
that's probably as far
as I'm going to push it.
I've dabbled with the idea of
trying Adderall but never jumped in.
And it just seems to me
be a little fucking iffy.
Well,
I heard about these guys,
I'm like,
well that sounds great.
And then I read this and I'm like,
Oh yeah,
you can't do that.
You know,
like it's,
it's like the monkeys,
Paul,
right?
Like there's a,
there's a price you pay for the thing.
Tim Ferriss calls it the
biological free lunch.
She says there's no
biological on free lunch.
Whenever you have something that
has like a very powerful action,
there's going to be an equal reaction.
Yeah.
And what he was talking about was,
um,
a think called provigil.
Have you heard a provisional?
Yes,
but tell me what it is.
I've heard of it,
but tell me it's a smart drug that a lot
of the sort of a silicon valley dudes
apparently are on because it's doesn't
seem to have a discernible side effect
for some folks.
Some people get rashes and some people
biologically it doesn't jive for them.
But for other folks it's like,
it's like martyr,
it's fucking super pill.
Right.
Super Cool.
It makes you like,
like super energize.
Your mind works really
clear but it's not speed,
but it's real sketchy.
Like Whoa,
why did we price?
Yeah,
I've done it a couple of times
and every time I do and I'm like,
man,
what is going on with this stuff?
It's fucking super strong man.
Really?
Yeah,
it's really powerful.
Like I took a half a pill and
it lasts for like six hours.
And your aunt did a weird way to,
cause you're not amped like a a guy
like you talked too jacked up on coffee.
Yeah.
It's great if you have to drive,
if you have to drive like I,
I won't hesitate to take it.
If I'm in a four hour drive and you know,
I'm worried about sleeping at the wheel
because you will not sleep at the wheel
if you take this stuff right,
if it jives with your biology.
But it's a tricky one.
Like a lot of people that
doesn't jive with their biology.
I wanted to get out,
I want to get a
prescription for it so bad.
It's just because I have to do so many
times where I'm just really tired.
You know,
I'm working these studs the Lord too.
Even from coke like you're like,
ah,
this part,
it would be fun if I was awake.
Have you ever tried Kat?
Do you know what that stuff that's
stimulant that those Somali pirates trying
Somali pirates are doing it.
I'm doing me,
they seem like rational fellows.
Good idea.
Good grip on reality.
It's going to work out
and I like their shoes.
Yeah,
the Somali pirates a,
that's one of the things that they,
uh,
the issue is that they're jacked
up on this and fit amine plant.
Right.
This is African amphetamines,
Africa,
where it was like,
this red is going around then you know,
like he,
I like sheep.
It's real cheap and South Africa,
the life course.
So it was life.
Right.
You hear about that guy
with no legs are shot.
His girlfriend,
his story is South African Guy,
the sprinter,
the Olympic sprinter.
I love his name,
his story.
It's because it's like the most Afrikaans,
like Dutch name Pastorius
and he's from notorious,
oh,
that's funny.
It many a apparently constantly
he thought it was she,
they thought he mistook
her for a burglar at first,
but then they realize no,
no,
he just fucking wigged
out and shut us out.
South Africa.
No,
never.
I was in,
so I sailed across the Indian Ocean and
then I quit this job and I got off in
South Africa,
Australia.
What was after I'd been
living in Thailand,
right.
And fighting and I went back to Australia.
I got on a boat.
What to uh,
across the Indian Ocean,
doing what is working,
what kind of job.
But it was it a mate,
a friend of mine was taking his
little 38 foot Hans Christian with his
girlfriend who was a friend of mine.
Uh,
so it was the three of us
for five months across God.
But one of the things you never really
seen when you're saying them like that,
you don't really see anybody
because you're sleeping.
He's up and then he's sleeping Europe.
You know what I mean?
It's not like you're put the three of
you were on a boat for five months.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh my God.
Five months.
Just you were the only people you saw?
No,
no.
We got off a couple.
We had stopped like three or four times.
Right.
So
I stopped it like Maricia said reunion.
So you may go a month with all 20 days,
something like that.
What did you eat with food?
We brought food,
tons of canned food and gets fish.
But yeah,
tons of canned food and stuff
and rice and whatever water.
Uh,
yeah,
it was fun.
And you couldn't handle it though.
When you went to got to South Carolina,
I was ready to get the fuck out of there.
So we hit Durban and I quit and
I bummed around South Africa for,
I don't know,
maybe six months,
tease us dude.
And here Trey,
Indiana.
Yeah.
You're always going to places that
you could die real easy from bugs.
Right.
Where was I?
What was that story and the story
from people being separated?
Oh no it how dangerous South Africa.
It's crazy because like this girl who
became my friend who sort of like adopted
me for some reason a Durban,
um,
she had all these scars because,
uh,
she has guard dogs,
you know,
cause it's,
it's dangerous place.
They had guard dogs and the maid came in
the wrong door on the wrong day and the
dogs killed the Guy Dave made and she
was in there fighting the dogs trying to
pull in the black made these dogs are
trained to attack black people and she got
shredded and the dogs killed the maid.
And that was like,
oh yeah,
that's what happened.
And it,
it'll night you drive around,
you run red lights,
you don't stop.
Oh my God.
So he was just worried
about getting caught.
Yeah.
You just don't do it.
How much more dangerous
or South Africa then?
Like Detroit,
um,
you towards getting there.
Right.
I don't know.
I've met in Detroit and just like decide
the color scale you have for stress was
like the South Africa scale.
Yeah.
I went to a close here to South Africa.
I went to Panama and Panama City and
then apparently that's like co Cologne.
It's apparently really
dangerous and it was bad,
but as long as you kept moving,
it was all right.
It was the kind of thing
where if you stayed,
you would have gotten jumped.
We uh,
we had,
uh,
one of the guys from a vice on
that said that the Karachi a bad,
apparently Shane Smith,
who's the head of Vice Awesome Guy,
we've had them on a few times.
I love,
love that guy.
He's amazing.
He's been all over the world.
But he said Karachi,
he said,
your life's worth about 20 bucks,
right.
You can hire a hit man.
To kill you for 20 bucks.
I can't be on the street.
Millions of people.
And they pull up and just shoot
people and just hop on their mind.
It's in Pakistan,
Karachi and Pakistan.
Yeah.
Let me see.
All rightey Pakistan.
Yeah.
I never really did.
I mean,
anyway,
yeah,
a lot of,
but you know,
most,
a lot of towns in Pakistan,
in Africa,
you know,
after dark,
dangerous after dark.
When we look at our life that
we have today in society,
I mean,
look at us living here in Los Angeles,
the greater Los Angeles area.
It's so Goddamn cushy compared to some
spots in the world and what it used to be
too.
Like,
you know,
like we're talking about,
what you're come from,
what you would have been normally
dealing with and it's just,
you're never hungry.
You never cold food is five minutes away.
Like if the apocalypse comes or the
people in the Congo gonna even know.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
You're going to operate as you.
Has Anything changed?
No.
One I did.
So at part of the book I
went up to the Inuit up in,
uh,
in um,
northern Canada.
Oh,
did the Igloo and the sea
ice and stuff like that.
And again,
if the apocalypse comes like,
yeah,
they'll notice because they'll be gas,
you know,
after a year or two that were on the gas
and they'll be back to their sled dogs,
you know.
But other than that,
they're fine.
What did you do with the it up then?
I did,
um,
I just bummed around for a couple
of weeks and did old thing,
go somewhere and fuck off
for a couple of months.
Well,
I would've gone on for longer,
but now I have a kid.
I don't do it anymore,
but uh,
you know,
I did this,
see I smell.
So I did like built an Igloo.
I did a little sled dogging
and did some of this stuff,
which is,
which was totally fun.
Now when you build an Igloo,
how comfortable,
I mean,
how hold was about outside
and how comfortable is it
actually inside the Igloo?
It's still pretty cold.
I mean,
you know,
in your,
you would have to raise up your bed a
little bit cause otherwise you melt into
the ice,
you put branches down or something.
One of the things about surviving
really cold is like conduction.
So touching things will
suck heat out of you.
So if you could,
you've got to get off the ground and
puts something between you and the ground
or you know,
really worn boots have,
haven't really fixed soul to
keep your feet off the nose.
Okay.
No right snow Kim.
It has kinda insulate but you still
don't want to be touching it cause you'll
melt into it.
Your body a warmer,
nothing,
nothing too.
And then they get you wet
and wet will kill you,
you know.
So inside the Igloo,
I think it would be like
a round zero degrees.
Wow.
Or a little bit below,
but,
but um,
you know,
outside of this 20,
30 below and there's no vegans
in the annual communities,
it's almost all hunter know,
gather.
I mean,
they eat,
they just hunt the hunter
[inaudible] I said you have to,
right?
Yeah.
And they don't,
they get supplied by the
Canadian government now and they,
they,
they're kind of been forced into towns.
It's actually really
depressing because there's,
you know,
there's no roads.
They had the Internet,
um,
but there's no road.
So they plan tickets like four grand to
fly to Montreal so that these kids grow
up there and they,
you know,
this town's 1200 people and they have
MTV and they have the Internet and then
they get movies and stuff,
but they really can't leave,
you know,
it's very,
very hard to make enough money to leave.
And so there's a lot of,
you know,
it's in it's native American community.
So there's what traditionally those
problems are alcoholism and all those,
you know,
not being a part of the
culture and all that stuff.
And what is the main foe occupation there?
They do,
you know,
there's,
there's some mining s support stuff
and exploration support stuff.
There's some tourism stuff,
you know,
people go up there and do trips.
Um,
and then there's hunting and gathering.
You know,
there's,
so do they sell this is they do some
crafts and stuff like that and they do
carve,
carve and,
and uh,
sell furs probably,
you know,
they're allowed to hunt anything.
I think whales are the,
they have a limit on the
whale quarter they can take,
but they hunt polar bear and they hunt
seals.
Polar bear.
Yeah.
I didn't get to,
but yeah,
they do polar bears.
And then we,
we got a Caribou while I was there,
you know,
but I didn't get to do it.
But they,
uh,
they have,
they like to play.
They're like,
you know,
they,
they stock the land like death.
I mean,
they just kill everything
because it's not my stair.
Well,
and this guy,
he's 60,
he was born in the Igloo.
Wow.
He has this born in England,
right.
Has the stories about his mom having to
kill a dog to survive because they were,
they were starving.
So,
you know,
he comes directly from absolute survival,
starvation,
the edge of it,
you know.
And so of course they kill,
you know,
more than they need.
And they put it in a
storage for the village.
I guess things don't get bad
because it's zero degrees outside,
so he'd just have a hole in the ground.
That's the huge advantage is that
you live in a freezer and they,
you know what Eskimo means?
It means people who eat raw meat in the,
in the Indian language.
Is it a,
a s instead of a slur,
the word as kind of a little bit,
it's,
they call themselves the,
into it.
And it would just means
that it's not like Spec.
It's not that bad,
but it's,
it's,
you're uneducated if you call them that,
like Jap.
Yes.
I don't even know.
I can't just that the record.
And he's like,
there's a spectrum,
you know,
like with obviously nigger
being the worst ones,
except for black people when they
throw it around and each other,
that's fine,
you know,
then it's fine or rappers or whatever.
Or Quintin Tarantino.
But if you,
uh,
you go from that to like Guinea,
like Italians,
we'll call each other guineas
and it's not that big a deal.
It's like it does it.
Cracker,
cracker six kind of add but not that
like actually it can have a sense of an
endearment to it,
but cracker doesn't really,
I guess so maybe crackers
worse than getting on,
but they're not that effective.
Well and always ask him,
oh,
in that line.
I Dunno.
I don't think it's maybe even it's
milder than that cause there is like a
logistic logical historical.
So the Indians when they were introducing,
um,
the French to these people,
they're like,
oh,
they're the people who eat raw meat.
Eskimo is the,
in the,
uh,
cro language or something like that.
So they,
why is that bad that this is,
this doesn't seem like
they call themselves.
Right.
Okay.
So it's not that bad,
but they just don't,
they,
I always thought that if you
used the word and you wait,
you were an asshole.
I was just trying too hard.
Oh really?
At the end you'd people shut up.
They do a lot of throwback Eskimos.
You fuck,
but I didn't know.
Then someone told me that
Eskimos a slur and I was like,
oh,
okay.
But we're getting to the point where
pretty much everything's a slur getting,
you know,
did you see the guy
who was the head of um,
uh,
Bravo had to apologize
for using the word twink?
No.
Yes.
And he's gay.
Let's twink mean twinks a weird gay guy.
Like a skinny gay guy.
Looks like a,
like a little boy.
The calm twinks.
Really?
Yeah.
He had to apologize for using the twic
cause apparently damage the twinks got
offended.
So sensitive.
And again,
I think a lot of that,
this sensitivity,
this ridiculous over.
Yeah.
It's because of the fact that we're
not dealing with real survival issues.
So we look for things to bicker about.
Yeah.
Know you think about sports,
like entirely sports.
It's like
because you don't have survival concerns.
Yes.
So you watch,
I mean,
I always think about it like
you watch other men to sort of,
you know,
because of the caveman thing and see,
do I want that guy hunting with me?
Don't want them with me.
But that's the whole thing.
It's like we're addicted to watch it.
It touches everybody.
We all have a genetic predilection to
watch men do shit because it's got a
survival,
you know,
impetus.
And yet,
you know,
that's all it is.
It's like,
and it's like a,
it's sort of absurd,
you know?
And yet it's,
it's,
you know,
it's the biggest thing in the world.
It's sort of observed,
but yet it's also sort of natural that
it's this kind of bridge between our
civilization and our ancient history.
Yeah.
It's really strange prowess.
It keeps us active.
It keeps us in the mix,
which is observing,
gauging,
you know?
Yeah.
Common Russian.
Gauging domination and caging.
There's a chart and what we value,
it's very strange.
It is.
What's really strange is that
if you look at it as a pattern,
as you said,
you know about the,
our modern civilization.
If you looked at the book
of the history of the world,
our modern civilization
is like a one sentence.
A couple of paragraphs.
Yeah.
And if you look at where
we're going and you see this,
this sort of,
these trains trends,
and look at us as hunter
gatherers 10,000 years ago,
look at us as,
or you know,
wherever it was in history,
and look at us today and look at
what is 10,000 years from now.
It's uh,
it's impossible to gauge.
It's too confusing.
It's too alien.
And there's a lot of
people that hate sports.
There's a lot of people that hate jocks
and meatheads and the whole idea of the
male dominator culture.
That's sort of this leftover thing.
But what is the alternative?
Because I wonder what are I going to do?
Are we going to be,
the alternative is very,
it's,
it's very confusing when you're talking
about synthetic skin and the ability to
recreate brain cells in,
in,
in a laboratory up.
Yeah.
I mean,
what do they,
what are they trying to meet?
They're going to make
another tronic brain.
They're going to make electronic
bulletproof brain when computers,
when artificial intelligence
is start building art,
other artificial intelligence,
all that stuff you'll all
off on you don't get crazy.
They see that that's the big worry is
not the invention of the artificial
intelligence.
It's what the artificial
intelligence does.
It becomes sentience,
is that it will improve upon the design
that are fucking measly brains have
created and improve upon it.
10,000 years worth of evolution and then
a couple of weeks they'll just have the
apocalypse robo apocalypse.
Did you and I will still give me a blurb.
He liked the book.
Ah,
he's awesome.
Oh,
unfortunately Steven Spielberg
decided to not do that.
Is that what happened?
And do some other fucking stupid piece
of shit movie that no one's going to like
about a dog.
No,
no,
no.
What did he just do?
What's his last name?
I guess robot apocalypse also.
You worry about like it's cool to
sort of a very I robotic in theory.
Yeah.
Was it was,
it was interesting.
I mean I think Daniel Watson is a
really interesting robotic wise.
You mean storywise?
Yeah,
that's good.
I hadn't read it.
We've had him on the podcast,
so it was really cool.
So I was rooting for him.
And then when I found out that they,
Steven Spielberg cancel
production in the Bronx,
I assumed it was because it was too good.
I assumed that that was a point where,
yeah,
Spielberg is a weird cat now.
Yeah.
Everything is four acts.
You're like,
all right.
Yeah.
Well I think a lot of those older
dudes that George Lucas type guys,
they get so much money and so much they
hit the spot where they made a million
awesome movies and then
it just is a little patty.
Is it theory?
As my wife has a isn't it makes
movies and one of her theories is,
uh,
it kill you.
You kill yourself to
make something really,
really good.
It,
you just kill yourself,
right?
You sacrifice your family and your,
your health and everything and then
you sorta don't want to do it again.
And then,
so you kind kinda do a little bit
less and everyone's still like,
oh,
that was amazing.
And you're like,
nobody fucking noticed
that I didn't kill myself,
so I'm going to keep doing it.
You know?
And then you start phoning
it in because you're like,
I want to have a regular life.
I want to work eight hours
a day or 10 you know,
I don't want to work 15 hours a day
for 300 days and not have a life.
Again.
I think there's that
motivation to push you.
Especially I think in the world of movies,
I think that's probably one of the most
difficult endeavors to make a giant
blockbuster film.
Like to make an Avatar.
Like here's a guy that was telling me
about James Cameron and he was like,
like Oh James Cameron such a Douche bag.
Like I had to work with
them on this movie.
He's such a con.
And I was like thinking about
like how lazy this guy is,
how annoying it probably be having this
guy worked for you when you're a guy
like James counter percent.
I'm going to make after talk everybody.
Yeah I'm making this,
we're doing it my way.
We're going to do this because I know
you don't know why cause you don't know
what's going on.
And everyone's like,
oh he's so hard to work with.
Yeah.
Cause he's trying to do something amazing.
Like,
you know what I mean?
And that's what it takes and it's,
it's I 100% agree.
Like people,
I mean that guy has a stud,
dude,
Cameron is a stud.
He's a bad motherfucker,
made so many awesome movies.
So he,
yeah,
he basically,
you know,
and you have to have that and you have,
people are like,
could you,
cause people want to do the easiest thing.
So like,
you know,
they're like,
oh,
it makes you feel good enough.
It's good.
It's really good.
See,
his intensity only exists
when it's your idea.
You don't have that intensity
when you're working for somebody.
You just don't,
you know,
the,
that's when it's your baby.
That's when it's your life,
when it's everything.
Otherwise you just maybe hit eight
and he's at 10 you might get a seven,
you're not going to get 10 and he
not going to want to pay that price.
And that fucking guy wakes
up or running at 10 you know,
and you're like,
oh Jesus now has an asshole to work for.
Yeah,
of course.
Like he's trying to do something
good and I'm just guessing,
maybe he is an asshole.
The fuck.
Do I know somebody listening to this man?
No,
no,
no.
Two shads an asshole.
He told me to repaint the
entire side of the boat.
It was the wrong color.
Gray.
Who cares about taught me,
this is a ridiculous,
but like Tom Cruise gets the wrong
sandwich and he threw it at the guy,
the assistant and everyone's like,
Tom Cruise is such a dick.
It's like dude,
I'm carrying this $150 million movie.
You're job is to get me the right
fucking sandwich and you're not doing it.
Like you know what I mean?
Like go get the wrong sandwich too.
Like it's all you have to do today
is bring Tom Cruise that right.
Sam,
I don't need any fucking confusion here.
I'm Tom Cruise.
I'm trying to do,
should have a lot of shit going on here,
man.
Scientology and my sexuality.
Sandwich confusion.
Do your job.
So I know,
I feel like that's a lot of times you
hear that about people and it's like,
cause it's also,
again,
it goes back to what we
were talking about earlier,
it's like this is artificial stress and
we've sort of created the end of the
day,
it's just a piece of entertainment.
It's a fucking movie.
Okay.
It's not running from a tiger.
It's a movie.
Goddammit.
No one should die making a movie.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Do you follow the walking dead?
You follow?
Like I don't follow it.
I know,
I know a little bit about comic books.
Oh yeah.
World War.
He was like one of my favorite books.
So,
and that it so funny it
was pitching this book.
I was like,
yeah,
I'm gonna do this.
And they all like,
and all these New Yorker,
this is,
you know,
before walking dead comes
out and they're all like,
zombies,
nobody's gonna read this.
You're crazy
now.
Zombies are everywhere.
No,
there's Zombie porn now.
Oh,
I'm not surprised.
There's CGI porn that people are
creating and that is so close to like,
it's like,
it's pretty obvious that
it's not really people,
but it looks enough like real people
that you could beat off to it.
I mean,
you're not going to get confused,
but there's some porn where it
leads the way and a lot of things.
Technology,
fucking monsters banging chicks
with their big monster dicks.
And you're like,
who is this?
The Japanese Japanese with Japanese.
It's an American Pankaj there's a,
there's this weird sort of a
Zombie thing that's going on.
Well they have a,
there's a movie now like a twilight.
What does chicken falls in
love with the Zombie yet?
Well,
you've got to the point that with
the Zombie genre you're getting into,
like you have to fizzling out.
Awesome.
Yeah.
You have to do the next thing,
right?
Which is like when does
the unforgiven of theirs?
Like I always feel like unforgiven kind
of like ended the western in a way.
You know,
like it's,
it's like the Uber most
perfect western ever made.
It's one of my favorite movies of all
time me to be the best movie ever made.
But it's like,
what's the western?
You can't do it western anymore.
It's really hard.
Like you'd make fun of Westerns
or you do it satirically or,
and I feel like there's Zombie genres.
It's headed that way.
And you know,
I have a friend who's making World War
z with Brad Pitt and I'm real curious to
see how that comes in.
What happens.
I am legend.
Uh,
no,
I,
you know,
I think the CG zombies heard it.
Yeah.
Guys in Zombie costumes are
much scarier than CG zombies.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
I see what you mean.
They love the,
with their mouths open and it was
pretty obviously a little fast and yeah,
something about it that
doesn't quite read where Eva,
did you see the gray?
Yes.
Like I think if it had been real wolves,
I would have been more scared.
Really?
Yeah.
I Dunno.
They looked pretty real.
Did you liked it?
Thought they looked real hard.
I thought the behavior that
they exhibited is not really,
the bowls are much more
concerned with survival and that,
you know,
if they'd lost a few
wolves to these people,
they probably steer clear.
They wouldn't hunt them and
dramatic pace of the movie.
Yeah,
this and that.
But the way they were separating
them from other people,
you know,
but I thought I was like,
man,
that's a little clever.
But I guess I guess what they're doing
is they're making something fiction and
I'm willing to,
yeah,
yeah.
Go on the ride.
Yeah.
I'm willing to go on that ride.
Mommy wrote the gay off on
opion Anthony this week.
Joe,
what it gay off on the Anthony
Opie and Anthony this week?
Yeah.
No.
What are you talking to?
You got to download.
You can download off audible.
It was like last Wednesday I think it was.
They had a gay off the first annual gay
off Andrew Dice Clay is in studio and
what they do is they
take four married guys.
They bring their wives
and these guys are like,
haven't done gay stuff before ever and
they have to do gay stuff in front of
their wise to try to win $1,200 and it
got to the point where they ended up
bringing like this guy from Craig's list
and that was a gay escort or something
like that.
I can't remember that.
A dancer and at 1.1 guy's like jacking
him off with oil while making out with
him.
The other guy's putting his
nose on his ass hole and it was,
it was some of the most
funniest shit I've ever heard.
Andrew dice clay lasted
like 10 minutes in it.
Like he got to the point where
they were tickling each other.
He goes,
oh this is pretty good.
And then like the next one was like
something like LDF at mouth kiss.
He's like,
I'm Outta here.
He just left.
I love your dice.
Oppression.
Terrible.
It's like a combination
of bum delouis and dice.
And that's another thing I is Opi does.
If you listened to any episode that
Andrew Dice Clay is in studio opiate has
this,
I'm moving here now.
Kind of like,
like kind of like a commentary
Tina with black people.
It's a little east coast on them.
It comes out really bad.
Well it's fun to talk like dice.
Yeah.
Oh,
you know when you have Dyson
and whenever we have minutes,
it's almost contagious.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know if I want to be in the room,
I dudes at Jack and dudes
off a mouth kissing.
I'd want to just give them the tickets
or whatever the fuck they're getting.
What do they,
what would they be?
It was only like $1,200 and they got
to the point though where it got so
horrible that their wives were,
yeah.
The two guys tapped out and
the other two were like,
I'm in it to deal with that.
Most of them were like,
this is hilarious.
This is funny.
A couple of 'em got creeped out like
I've never even seen porn before.
And then I see my husband
do it and all right,
the clear the palate.
Have you seen this though?
The happy elephant?
What this is,
I've seen,
it's like one of the best videos ever.
I go,
if you go onto youtube and look at it,
it's just an elephant that's having
fun in the ocean and it's like charging
waves and it's like,
it's like he's just having
the time of his life.
It is it just a super positive
animal because they're really intelligent
and they have an amazing memory.
You know,
always people,
they make that sort of a connection
to elephants and memories.
But you know,
because one of the ways to train an
elephant as you tie them to a something to
their leg and you put a stake in the
ground when they're young and they don't
have any strength and they always
remember that they can't move that steak.
So even though they get big
and they're much stronger,
they can easily pull free.
They don't because they
sort of remember that.
But they've done these,
a reintroductions of elephants that
haven't seen each other for over 20 years
and they go crazy.
They run rug and grab each other.
They recognize each other right away.
Even though the US fucking elephants
all basically look the same.
Totally speciesist end because they
ended up shooting it cause it was on a
resort.
You Imagine Ted Nugent comes out riding
a buffalo and puts one in the silence.
Yeah.
I watched his,
one of his,
uh,
hunting shows where you shot an elephant.
And I'm like,
wow,
really?
Dude.
And they were talking about how it's
important to shoot elephants because
there's too many of them now.
Yeah.
Cause,
uh,
they're destructive to the
environment and they're crowded out.
Yeah.
They have to call the herd.
They do.
Nobody wants to hear that though.
You know?
I know it's tough,
dear thing too.
Like I've had conversation with people,
but deer and,
uh,
they're like,
well,
I don't think I could ever shoot a deer.
And I don't think I support hunting
because you could always just like,
listen,
we're raising cattle for food.
You should just see cattle.
Okay.
But they gonna fuck
those deer going to fuck.
And then what happens?
Well,
you know,
we're raising every lane.
Basically,
we're raising everything.
You know,
we're raising deer to,
you know,
just a little more indirectly.
Yeah.
And certainly like the,
you know,
the elk population out did some elk
hunting in Colorado for the book and that,
you know,
you have to kill,
killing females is,
there's more females in math,
like a lot more.
So they need,
they're trying to keep the herd and
balance and it's important what you really
should do if you're going
hunting is killed babies.
Whoa.
Because they might not survive the winter
anyway and that meets just going to
waste.
They're rotting in that.
So use your tag.
It's really,
that's really hard to do.
But kill Bambi.
Right.
That's the,
that's the real tough one.
That's what you should do.
Yeah.
Again,
on the Ted Nugent saw or some he,
cause he would bow and Arrow hunts
and I don't know like what limits,
there are tagged limits,
but he shot three deer in a day.
I Dunno.
Thought maybe it's on his own property.
It is on his own property.
I don't know.
But I guess he's,
maybe he's doing,
you know,
like a population management.
So one of them was like this little baby,
they jack with a polling out.
I'm like,
whoa.
Yeah.
Actually bowhunting somebody I'd like
to get into because it's so hard and not
deer,
not like sitting in a stand,
which is a lot of deer hunting,
but like elk hunting,
which is you have to pursue,
you have to like track,
you'd have to like close.
I'll shoot it with 15 2030 yards,
you know,
as opposed to,
a hundred,
200 yards
and you got to do it most
of the time by herself.
Right.
And the guide who can close now it's
more sense you're making a mess,
you know,
so your,
your survival,
your chances are more better
than more people you like.
That's why it's really hard to
watch elk bow hunting on TV.
Cause you've got to have a camera man.
They're fucking everything up.
Cameron stomping on twigs
and shit about the new guy.
That was my dog.
Snap and the phone goes off,
ears pop up and it's like,
fuck this,
I'm out of here man.
Yeah.
Elk is a gigantic animals.
I don't think a lot of people
realize how big they are,
but there was,
um,
a lodge that we stayed in and,
uh,
they had an elk head on
the wall and the horns,
they're longer than my arm.
I mean,
literally it's,
this thing was massive,
like a 12,
1300 pound animal.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I got a female elk for this book
and she was 600 pounds and it was,
yeah,
it was,
was Christ 600 pounds.
How much we meet was that,
you know,
it was,
I dunno,
I think I had brought home,
I don't know,
I didn't let you know,
but a lot.
Yeah.
Three,
400,
you know,
I don't know.
At that point I want you to be 300,
250 pounds of meat.
Did you stalk it?
Like how did you,
yeah,
he hit the,
you have to like basically elk hunting
and where I wasn't southern Colorado,
you have to look essentially run.
Like it's because,
uh,
there are only coming out
at a very specific time and,
uh,
your scent is so
destructive to the they'll,
they'll take there,
they smell you at all.
They're going to be,
they're going to take
off and never come back.
So you don't go out and told their out.
You don't like go wait for him,
which is what,
you know,
like deer hunting is more,
you get in a blind and wait for him that
you actually look where they are and go
up and sneak around and you know,
I can run through the bushes taking into
account where the wind's blowing and he
tried to hunt,
hunt the wind.
So you have the wind blown with you.
And uh,
and uh,
yeah,
I uh,
I was with Don Yeager who is
chuck Yeager son Chuck Yeager's,
like the fighter fighter pilot,
the rope,
the speed of sound iconic.
Wow.
Um,
whose was it?
Bigger?
So Don Yeager who was a Vietnam vet,
it was a appointment in Vietnam.
Um,
and uh,
we've become friends,
long story,
that whole thing.
But he and his son,
his son is like a big hunter.
And also,
uh,
Iraq and Afghanistan vet.
Wow.
And,
you know,
they were in the,
in the trenches,
vets not all told.
How many different experiences did
you go through to write this book?
I don't know.
10 something like that.
You know.
So I did,
I tried what I tried to do with sort of,
you know,
have fun with it and keep it light and
in interesting and not dire and sincere
and sort of answer all your
survival scenario needs.
Like what if it's Mad Max?
Well,
I did a stunt driving school,
you know,
and I'm like,
what are some of the things about
stunt driving you didn't know?
Like,
you know,
you fixed the brakes so
you can pump the brake.
So getting the rear to lock is
how you do all those tricks.
So how you bust a one 80 and all that
stuff is by pumping the brake and they fix
it so you can pump it
like a break or you know,
even the one that you step on.
And,
um,
and then,
you know,
I did stuff like I stole a kind of
learned how to steal old cars with la La
Gangbangers,
loose cars,
you know,
and you know,
you can't steal anything recent,
recent,
you know,
but older cohort years,
like a good year to start stealing,
you know,
and like,
a 93 civics.
Great.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You just go in MPs.
Pop off all the,
all of us basically you pop off the stuff
from the steering column and you reach
in there with like a leatherman and we're,
or needle nose and just,
it turns out key really is that easy.
Yeah.
And then you sign it for GM cars.
He's size,
which I missed something in the column,
but you know,
anything after,
you know,
they have like electronic fail safes
and shut offs and chips in the keys and
stuff like that.
Did this book writing this book
changed the way you live your life?
Yeah,
little,
I learned a lot.
I mean,
it was just so much stuff I didn't,
I was just stunned,
you know?
And it really became like
mythbusters for a lot of things.
You know,
things I thought were true weren't true,
like about what I thought it'd be able
to do or what the realities of certain
situations were.
What was the most shocking?
Probably the stress when really was the
most mind blowing and really changed the
way I think about myself,
you know,
and what I can do,
why can't do and,
but you know,
there was,
I don't even know,
you know this,
it's just,
it all goes into the mix of like,
you know,
trying to understand the world,
which is what basically
what I'm trying to do.
One of the things that I've thought was
really fascinating was that this book,
a lot of it seemed to emanate from where
you grew up and you grow up in a town
in Massachusetts.
It explained the story that they
were attacked by the Indians.
Hatchet marks on the fucking houses still
there.
Right.
So I grew up in a town
called old Deerfield mass,
which is like a little
bit like Sturbridge,
like it's partial,
half the town is his museum.
And because it was very famously at 17,
oh four,
the Indians and French,
uh,
came down from Canada and massacred the
whole town and marched off 150 captives
in the winter all the way up to Canada.
And,
you know,
a lot of them made it and it was crazy,
but,
um,
people were tough.
You know,
it's again,
like you can't even compare
the toughness from 1702 to now,
you know,
but,
uh,
but yeah,
and so I grew up in this town where,
you know,
there were a lot of,
the Indians had to act a whole and the
store and shot the guy through the door.
And,
you know,
these stories are kind of what I grew up
with and they'd even do recreation's as
a kid.
I remember like,
you know,
guys as Indians are screaming in the
night running around and killing other
people that were dressed as colonials,
you know,
and like when you're in a
recreation in a recreation,
but when you're like,
you know,
five years old,
that shit sticks.
You know what I mean?
That goes deep.
So like,
I think I definitely,
I kind of realized in
this book that I was like,
kind of preparing for the Indians to
come over the wall and certain with my
whole life,
you know what I mean?
With like,
you know,
with the fighting stuff and with,
uh,
with everything,
you know?
Yeah.
I loved that.
That realization that you had in the book,
I thought,
I found it really fascinating and I just
couldn't imagine what it must be like
growing up in a town where there's real
clear evidence of the hatchet marks on
doors and shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
you knew it was,
it was a long time.
It was right,
but still is a little kid.
You're like,
I would wake up and there was
cornfields and I'd be like,
are they come through the corn?
Dude,
I do like,
you know,
and that they came in the winter,
it was ridiculous,
but you still,
it gets into your,
you know,
these things.
And again,
you were simple animals.
You know,
you're afraid of things.
You're not sophisticated on
how you deal with your fear.
You think you are and you
see a movie about something,
you believe it man.
And like you can say,
oh,
it's just move.
But you know what a big
party you does not know.
That's just a movie,
a big party.
You thinks huge sharks are in the water
and they will always think that because
the jaw,
you know what I mean?
There's a,
there's a,
there's a deceit that
goes on when people all,
it's just a movie.
I'm not fooled,
but you are fooled.
Yeah.
Sorta at some level.
On some level you believe it's possible.
Yeah.
On some level,
yeah.
It's um,
the,
the idea of living in a place where
you knew massacres took place.
Was Your town supposedly haunted?
Oh yeah.
There we go.
Surfing and stuff like that.
I never dealt with any of them,
but I had the people,
I had friends who had that conversation.
You believe in that?
Yes.
I've never seen it.
Right.
But I leave even like psychic
energy and stuff like that.
I mean,
listen,
I've been in places where I was
in an island in the Pacific.
Um,
there was actually Malcolm Forbes,
his private island,
um,
did,
the guy was sailing with new,
somehow we stayed there and it had been,
um,
it was a small island near not too far
from Fiji and the Fijians had come in the
night over a hundred years and eaten.
Everybody on the island did declare war
on this island and eaten everybody off
the island.
And you could tell like some
shit had gone down there.
I like,
there was a quiet Erie bad juice there,
you know,
for sure.
And also like,
you know,
those towns because you
knew or because there's no,
maybe,
I mean I could have been fooling myself,
but it was also like,
you know,
the Anasazi ruins and anyone
in New Mexico and stuff,
like I felt the same quietness there
that I kind of feel like there is,
there's so much we don't know.
I mean just know what you don't know.
I mean that's kind of like
my whole theory in life,
but there's a lot of that's out there
and I think there is psychic residue and
things like,
I mean people that go to
Auschwitz talk about it,
you know what I mean?
And I've never been and I'm
sure it would be something.
Yeah.
I wonder because the issue was always a,
you know,
you're going to Auschwitz.
Yeah.
But it's,
I,
I mean I'm not,
I'm not necessarily a skeptic as much.
I am just always asking questions.
But the,
um,
the psychic connection between people,
I've heard like arguments
about answering the phone.
Like,
do you know the no person's going to call
you thinking about them and then they
call you today.
I was hanging around with
a friend of mine and I was,
I stepped,
we opened this door and I had an a very
obscure lyric playing in my head to a
1970 song.
And this motherfucker behind
me starts singing it and I go,
why didn't you just sing that song?
And he goes,
it's a good song.
I go,
why don't you just sing that song?
It goes that songs in my head,
I go,
I was singing the fucking words to that
song in my head before we walked through
the door.
You said the exact lyric.
I was thinking that could
be easily coincidence,
but God,
I mean,
it's a popular song
and it's a famous song.
There's things going on that you know,
like it's,
you know,
there's brainwaves and energy.
Yeah.
But we get like a Sam Harris
Dude in here who are like,
oh,
statistically it's like,
are the possibilities,
the probabilities and just luck and
you're connecting all the significance to
luck.
And it might be bright too.
I don't know.
But man,
it was freaking me out because I thought
the exact words that this guy was
singing behind me and they're from a
fucking song written for decades ago.
You know,
it's like there's been a lot
of songs between now and then.
That's kind of crazy.
So it give you,
yeah,
no,
I think there is a lot of
forms of communication that,
that,
you know,
emotionally,
pheromones sense.
You know what dogs are seeing
with dogs are hitting off of,
you know,
the cat that comes in lies down on
people two days before they die.
You know,
a creepy fucking cat.
He's sucking your soul out result.
Stupid knows there's smells you give
off when you're going to whatever.
But I think there's,
there's just,
you know,
this more than to the Earth
and heaven and hell are you?
Rupert Sheldrake believes that everything
has some sort of a memory or he's got
a theory about everything.
Having some sort of a memory and
that our ideas of memory are,
you know,
we think that memory is ours.
We have a memory,
animals have memory and that's it.
But what,
what he believes is that actual
objects may also contain some sort of
information about what's already
taking place in that area.
And that's one of the reasons why
when you go to historic places,
it gives you a strange feeling.
Well,
that's what I'm talking about.
Like,
yeah,
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure it's impossible.
Like if something really bad happened
somewhere that you might pick it up later.
I don't really know.
I think it's,
we're,
I think we're more sensitive.
You know,
there's a great book,
uh,
Gavin de Becker wrote the gift of fear,
which is all by intuition,
you know,
and you should trust your
intuition in certain situations.
You know,
like,
don't,
if somebody's freaking you out,
don't try to be nice to them.
You know what I mean?
Like there's,
there's a reason maybe you don't
see it and that right away,
but don't force yourself to be polite.
And anyway,
it's a cool book.
I am a big believer in that.
I don't know why,
but maybe because of my own personal
success with following that,
that I've trusted my intuition
like implicitly my entire life.
Like that's the one thing that I've
trusted my entire life that I don't think
it's ever fucked me.
Well,
the danger is when you
trust it for systems,
it can't that
that are too big.
Right?
But you're never going to run
into a 600 foot tall man on the,
you know,
that's never going to happen.
But you could in the stock market,
you know what you mean?
You couldn't,
you couldn't,
in other situations where it's impossible
to have a 600 that you're just not
ready for.
You know what I mean?
Your intuition is not good.
It's not designed for them.
Something as complex as
that system is just too big,
you know?
Yeah.
I think that's interesting because that's
sort of along the lines of what we've
been talking about is that our own
bodies are not designed for this world.
That we're living in the possibilities
that are created by the suburb we live
in.
And your instincts,
right?
Sort of like plugged into
something like the stock market.
I've got a hunch,
ah,
you don't have shit.
You might be right,
but you might be dealing with
something that's impossible.
And also,
you know,
guys who picks the machines
that pick stock markets,
stocks at random do fine.
You know what I mean?
They do just as good
as most stock brokers,
you know,
so it's,
but,
but your intuition is really
good for personal relationships.
You know,
four things you would encounter
on the plains of Africa.
Right?
Danger,
you trust height,
you know,
why you're scared of heights,
certain situations.
And you know,
a lot of times they talk about,
you're picking up a lot of
silent cues or cues that are,
your conscious mind is not picking up.
Like,
you know,
the cop who,
he knows something's going on and he,
when he walks into the store and he's
not remembering that he saw a guy sitting
outside with the car running
and cigarettes or something
cute him to the fact
that there's something
hinky going on and you,
maybe he missed it consciously,
but subconsciously he's there.
You or the energy,
he can feel the energy of someone
who is trying not to get busted.
I mean,
who knows what vibe they're giving off.
Yeah.
It's the whole broad spectrum of senses
is very strange because there's been
certain studies that show that there are
some intangible qualities then we can
pick up on statistically like they've
shown that people can tell when people are
looking at the back of their head.
Right.
Yeah.
More than 50%.
It's like,
it's statistically significant.
Yeah.
Get significant.
We talk about the hunters,
gays,
you know,
we don't look at the animal,
until you're ready.
Cause it can feel you.
Yeah.
And,
and dawn sometimes,
and the snipers we'll talk about,
like you,
you have to look down and not only do,
you have to not look at your target,
you have to not think about it.
You got to go blank.
They have to go.
I'm a log in the log in my log.
This is a fucking awesome book.
I'm only three or four chapters in.
Where am I at?
Tell you where I'm at.
Um,
uh,
I'm thinking I'm naked
into the wilderness,
so I guess I'm the nine
in this John Macpherson.
It's fucking great stuff.
Thank you.
But it's a real page Turner.
I really,
I'm,
I'm enjoying the shit out of it.
Um,
like I said,
I started reading it this weekend and
I've been glued to it every night.
The disaster diaries by my man,
Sam Sheridan,
not Sam Sheridan on Twitter.
You got to go to fighter's mind.
I know you like Joe Rogan.
I can't remember that shit.
I can't remember it either.
But when
you type it into Twitter,
have you type the Tam,
Sam Sheridan into the search,
it will find fighter's mind.
That's the one you want.
Does it have a little,
do you have a little chalky
thing next to your name?
They verify your ass.
I'm sure that innocent
was checked to see that,
right?
No,
you will not verify.
I'm not very good at no damn man.
You can't even get a Wikipedia page pitch.
I know Wikipedia be hating on you.
Well,
it's because too many people tried to
make me a Wikipedia page and then it just,
now it's like they think
it's spam or something.
You think that,
I think someone in
Wikipedia fucking hates you.
And that's what I think.
I got to get a look on your page.
You don't have a Wikipedia
page that's got three books.
And I got the people that the one pit
willing book who have porn together.
We start pouring to quit.
Everyone who's a porn star on Wikipedia.
So maybe you could do like a solo,
both of us and like in
the backyard we'll get on.
It sounds like the only way,
if you want to make it look,
we're talking about survival.
You gotta do what you gotta do.
Miss is Internet survival.
There's only one way to go.
Yeah,
there's,
there's no way to make it,
um,
this weekend.
Mad Flavor and I Aka Joey Diaz this Friday
night or going to be at the grove in
Anaheim a,
if you go to my,
um,
my Twitter page or my website,
you could find the,
uh,
the information,
but the grove in Anaheim
this Friday night,
me and Joey motherfucking Diaz,
we didn't do team today.
We'll do the tank tomorrow.
Sorry,
Tang,
uh,
go to [inaudible] dot com and you'll
save 25 bucks off of tings devices.
That's a Freebie Tang and
I'll hook you up tomorrow.
Tang is a calm down man.
A Tang is a settled,
a cell phone company that'd be working
with awesome cell phone company.
Totally,
completely,
uh,
not evil.
And a,
they have great cell
phones and great service.
And the way they do it is no contracts.
And you cancel anytime you like.
You could put more than one person on an
account and they have really cool high
end android devices like the Samsung
Galaxy s three and the Samsung note.
So it's all cool shit.
And uh,
we'll,
we'll do a full ting commercial tomorrow,
but go to [inaudible] dot com
save yourself 25 bucks fucker.
Hey Joe,
go to squarespace.com hold on a second.
squarespace.com forward slash Joe j o e
and you don't have to use a credit card.
Try it out.
You can just give it a shot and see
what it's like to build a website.
If you decide to purchase it,
use the code.
Offer the offer code Joe to Joe and the
number two and you'll get 10% off your
first purchase on a new accounts,
including monthly or annual
plants@squarespace.com forward slash.
Joe,
use the offer code Joe too.
All right,
you fucks.
Thanks to [inaudible] dot com go to o n
n I t use the code named Rogan and you
could save yourself money there.
You're dirty fucks.
I'm just saving you
cash like crazy.
What were you saying?
I'm going to be in San Diego next month.
I'm ready to swim with dolphins.
So I got a desk squad show on a March
14th and it's going to be a me and a
couple of guys who was
on the show with you.
I'm just not,
I just booked it today.
Okay,
so the comedy show is that where it's at,
the American comedy code.
You can go American comedy,
code.com uh,
tickets just went on sale today
and I think I'm going
to be bringing up like,
uh,
Tony Hinchcliffe and maybe Brody and a
couple of other guys are going to be at
four guys.
Cool.
And if people want to find that,
I'll follow it.
Just go to red ban on Twitter.
R E D B a.
N.
And why don't you follow him?
Because I don't think
he has enough people.
How many people we got now?
Not,
not many.
That's ridiculous.
You should have more.
79 bucks.
Go there and follow him.
It's only twice as much as man.
See Ya.
All right.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you very much Sam.
Amazing Book.
Thanks brother.
You're always a
fascinating guy to talk to.
Let's do this more often.
Anytime,
anytime by this book he freaks.
It's a great book.
You'll enjoy the shit out of it.
And if you're an MMA fan,
you must buy fighter's
heart and fighter's mind.
They're both fantastic books.
I believe the two best
books written on MMA and uh,
this is the best book I've
ever read on disasters.
This is the fucking shit people tomorrow.
James the Colossus Thompson.
When Brian Callan Thursday,
Dana white finally got Dana white coming
in this this Thursday because we've got
a big UFC this weekend.
All Right,
folks,
we love you and we'll talk to you soon.
Thank you.
Oh.